I wish I knew like foreign languages,
so I can say something like,
you know,
ball,
swamp tsunamis.
But I don't know what that means.
So I might be saying something stupid.
Hello everybody in English,
this episode of the podcast brought to you by Squarespace,
which we were talking about before the podcast even began.
So we're not bullshitting you when we tell you it's awesome.
Powerful.
Nick Usif used the Squarespace.
Uh,
Brian's made at least 20 or 30 websites,
right?
If you had to guess.
Yeah,
yeah,
probably.
It's super easy to do.
It used to be a huge pain in the ass if you wanted to get a website,
unless you were super lucky and knew some guy who was awesome and it was easy to
deal with.
Like me,
I have found an awesome guy.
But if you,
uh,
my friend Menthol,
but if,
if you don't find that you're fucked,
you know,
you've got to try to learn coding yourself.
Good luck.
It's difficult.
And it's also,
it used to be really difficult to mash things up.
Like for,
uh,
one browser.
It would look great,
but then you'd see it in safari.
It would look all wonky or you know,
it worked good with a windows,
but it wouldn't work with a Mac or whatever it was.
There was always issues with compatibility,
like iPhone compatibility.
A lot of times that would be squirrelly.
Squarespace,
they have it set up where your website,
we'll work on everything.
It'll work on an android phone and I'll work on an iPad and a work on one of
those,
those tablets of unknown origin that you,
uh,
run various operating systems on.
It's just fucking works.
Works awesome.
We could set up an online store,
super easy to do.
Just point and click,
drag and drop.
They have 24,
seven support.
It's simple,
easy,
beautiful designs and it looks completely professional.
Like look at this website.
He slapping together a website right now,
a use of website and he can do it like that.
Just pee.
I mean it's,
it comes out like,
like you hired somebody,
like you spend a lot of money and you could bang them out quick.
They just got it wired.
They figured it out.
Like there's no need to to go anywhere else anymore.
You can make your own shit,
especially if you are even remotely,
creatively inclined,
but you were just technologically ignorant.
You know,
if,
if that was the case,
this is super easy to use.
Squarespace has a logo creator.
You can create a clean,
simple logo design for yourself in minutes for a free trial and 10% off your
first purchase.
Go to squarespace.com and entering the code word Joe Squarespace.
A better web starts with your website.
That's what they make you say.
That's their part.
It's really easy.
It's,
it's so drag and drop.
Like if you want a map like sick,
if you have a store and you went to Google map,
I love them.
I'm going to eventually get right there.
That one great.
If I get some time,
I want to make my own website.
That's fun.
I made mine in like four hours,
but the one you just made is better than mine.
Um,
we're also brought to you by ting.
I got my new tank phone hear Ting is which the official,
I got the galaxy s five.
Cool.
Yeah,
just kind of,
I'm a phone Ho.
Uh,
he's my little phone or device.
Um,
it's dope little phone.
I like the fact that it's waterproof.
That's pretty slick.
That's the thing.
And they're all becoming waterproof to make so much more sense.
Yeah.
He dropped his phone in water,
dude.
Wow.
Yeah.
And it's just like what gets out of the water?
What bitch water resistant.
Some of them are actually waterproof,
I believe there's a Sony that's actually waterproof,
which is pretty fantastic.
A ting is a website or things,
a mobile service company that uses a sprint.
What they do is you buy your phone from them and then they,
they handle all the rest,
all goes to a sprint backbone.
But you do it by their rules and their rules are just a lot fair,
a lot easier for people to digest.
You know,
I think everybody enjoys paying for things that are worth it.
it's nice when you go to a good restaurant and he'd get a nice meal and you pay
for it.
You feel good about it.
It was a good experience.
I cut.
That was great.
You leave there,
whatever you spent was totally worth it.
It's always a shitty feeling when you know,
even if you enjoy something,
if you feel like you've got fucked over or you feel like it's too much,
I feel like it's not fair.
And for the longest time the weigh cell phone,
uh,
companies have done business has irked a lot of people.
One of the things being that you pay for your minutes,
like you know,
you have like this thing like 120 minutes,
but if you don't use that hundred 20 minutes,
you don't get any money back.
Like that money's just gone.
Like all the time is out in the ether.
And Ting was like,
well why do you have to pay for Shit you're not using?
How about this?
How about we work out a really simple way to do it where most people would save
money and we just do it by the minute.
Like whatever you use,
that's what you pay for.
And if you don't use that much,
you pay less.
And if you want to save money,
use your fucking phone less.
And they like,
you could really do that and ting figured out how to do it and I think that all
cell phone companies in the future,
I'm probably going to follow that model.
I think it's going to be one of those things like remember he used to pay for
roaming,
he'd get in your phone and you drive 20 minutes,
are you getting your car rather?
And you've had,
you have your phone on you at 20 minutes outside of the city,
you'd be roaming.
So it costs you like some ridiculous amount of money.
Where'd all that go?
All that shit went away.
It had to go away because companies like tin come along and they come up with a
better way to do it.
And um,
that's what I feel.
I think the minute,
the whole minute thing is going to go away soon because I was just thinking,
know how many minutes I,
a month I use on my cell phone talking,
I barely talk on my phone.
I can take these a minute a month.
I bet 10 minutes a month.
No doubt.
I Bet I I use 10 minutes a month that they charge for data now the same way they
used to charge for a minutes.
Yeah.
As minutes or like nothing.
Yeah,
man,
it's hard.
Nothing anymore.
I still don't totally understand.
And why
data is expensive.
It's confusing to me.
Like I get storing it would be expensive and I,
boy,
I don't understand it.
I mean,
is it electricity?
what does being used?
There's bandwidth,
right?
Yeah.
But what exactly is bandwidth?
Like this is how stupid I am stupid.
I am on something that I rely on on a daily basis.
I don't know Jack Shit about how the Internet works.
Yeah.
You're pretty much paying to use computers to transfer data to you.
So it's using computers.
It's way over priced and it should be definitely,
well,
the computer,
I don't know about all that because imagine if you had to reset it up yourself.
Hey,
you know
they quit,
right?
Everybody quit time to make a new internet.
Yeah.
How much would it cost?
How Wa,
how could you ever come up with four g on your own?
Not We,
we need these fuckers.
I Dunno how
it would be smoke signal.
That's the next step.
I'm like there's no internet.
I guess I'm yelling and starting fires.
Yelling louder shouldn't be.
We should be so happy.
People out there that are way smarter than us to figure that fucking thing out.
You know we would have never figured out the Internet.
There's some like that that just the evidence that the Internet is real.
That is one of the best evidence is that there are people that are just so far
beyond how fucking smart you think smart is.
It's like remember when you were like five or six years old you had like a lot
of times you had like this one kid in the neighborhood that maybe it was like a
little bit bigger,
a little bit stronger than the other kids and when you would play with them on
the field,
like you'd get like bummed out.
Like you get knocked over and shit like remember what you thought that was like
that was a strong little kid.
But if you were there right now,
you'd be like,
get out of here.
You little fuck fuck knocking in everybody,
you know.
You know what I mean?
I,
it was a more secured that he had freckles or something like that.
Yeah.
He'd be like,
get out he fucking
Weirdo.
Don't be mean to me.
I'm a grown ass man.
But that's what I feel like,
like technologically and,
and just the mental capacity of a super genius and comparison to me.
I feel like if a,
I'm that little kid and like if I tried to figure out how the fuck they figured
out the Internet,
I just be like,
oh,
brain isn't worked out good.
I can't talk to you.
You're freaking me out,
man.
You know,
if you,
if you went into one of those dudes offices and they had those crazy like
goodwill hunting shit on the wall and he's doing those equations that fucking
nobody understands,
you know,
that they'll work on for years.
You know,
even the professor didn't like,
how did you,
what does fuck yeah.
I remember like in goodwill hunting,
the fucking dumb,
the janitor fixes the problem.
They leave it open to the janitor can work on the problem.
Really?
Yeah.
What if he just erased it?
What if he's just crazy?
He's not.
Why you had channeled her bitch,
this is a stupid story.
Here's a super genius janitor.
Get the fuck Outta here.
The Fuck Outta here.
You're smarter than anybody.
You can figure out these equations and nobody else can and you're also
beautiful,
right?
What are the odds and charming
anyway,
rogan.ting.com go get a phone.
They're awesome.
They have all the best android phones.
Uh,
and I said,
like I said,
this one I got that's a waterproof is the galaxy s five
that's going to make the drought worse.
The galaxy s five [inaudible] in the shower for like two hours.
I didn't even think about that.
Not worrying about like the pool and shit.
Yeah.
I mean I remember when they were dipping phones,
there was like a company that would dip them,
like dip your iPhone and then they would send it back to you and essentially be
waterproof.
Is that what they,
that's probably what they did with Das.
They probably just dipped him maybe,
but did that work?
Probably work.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Did that work?
What?
Does anybody know what that worked?
I think for water resistance,
the it has to work.
It's not just dipping it.
I mean,
you could drop your phone in a toilet like all of us have and it's still work,
you know?
So the dipping it,
I mean even if it's 99% accurate,
it's still probably going to,
you know,
work enough.
Yeah.
I bet the fine print is like 20 pages long,
right?
It's gotta be under four minutes and all these other guys.
Yeah.
It's probably got to be like under 30 meters or something like that.
Probably have like a,
like what's like a good waterproof depth for a watch because they have squirrely
little rules.
So they'll say water resistant up to 30 million.
Well listen,
bitch,
waterproof or not.
I guess it's like water pressure.
Is that what it is?
That shit's legit.
I mean it,
it,
it hurts.
Your ears probably would fuck with your phone too.
It makes sense.
Anyway,
rogan.ting.com go there and save 25 bucks off a new tank phone.
He'd dirty savages.
And last but not least,
we're brought to you by on at.com.
It's O,
n n,
I t ana is what you would call it,
a human optimization website.
We sell strength and conditioning equipment.
We sell delicious snacks and foods like the warrior bar,
which is this,
somebody actually brought this up.
I think this is a,
an important point.
Somebody brought this up to me on Twitter.
There's no added nitrates in,
um,
in these buffalo bars,
but there's naturally occurring nitrates that occur in sea salt and celery.
So,
uh,
that's something to consider.
And also like,
I don't know whether or not,
like I was saying on this,
uh,
this ad before when I would read it before,
one of the points is that it has no nitrates.
And I don't know exactly if nitrates are actually bad for you in natural form.
I don't know if they're bad for you and sea salt form or bathroom salary or if
it's just,
uh,
an amount thing.
And I think that's a good question for a doctor,
Rhonda,
Patrick,
and she's,
uh,
she's going to be coming back.
We're exchanging email,
so hopefully I can get an answer for from her on this kind of stuff.
When it comes to health and anything,
like anything that's controversial diets and you know,
and supplementation and things along those lines,
I can't stress enough.
If you've got any questions about that kind of shit,
you got to Google it and you to read both sides.
It's not comfortable to do.
It's annoying.
Like say if you,
you think that like taking vitamin D is good for you and you're like,
wow,
I look,
let me go see,
oh,
there's a bunch of papers to say vitamin D is good for him.
He got to read.
Vitamin D is Bad for you.
You got to read his vitamin D bad for you and read that to read,
read whatever papers,
whatever studies they have.
If you don't,
you're kind of guessing.
Or if you know someone like Rhonda Patrick,
you can ask her.
That's why she's awesome.
Isn't nitrates what make you have boners?
No,
that's nitric oxide.
Boy.
I'm glad you're not a fucking doctor.
You gave him some shit that makes beef Jerky,
dude.
No wonder his dick didn't get our vitamin D bad.
Free.
No.
Dot.
Vitamin D excellent.
It's the thing that most people are deficient in apparently according to
numerous studies.
They say that most people,
like 70% of the population does not get enough vitamin D.
When I just had,
I had my physical,
that's the only thing that was wrong with me.
Everybody do it.
It's super common.
We're not getting enough sun.
People were supposed to be on the sun all the time,
you know,
we're scared.
Everyone's scared of camp.
I don't want to get the kid outside dairy too.
Right.
You get it a lot from dairy.
Doesn't dare give you cancer.
No,
no.
Vitamin D.
Yes.
You get it from milk,
so I'm probably very deficient and the cows are you really?
Yeah,
I'm getting there.
You should get your blood work done,
man.
Gay.
You should check it out.
If anybody's ever interested in really getting healthy and fit,
getting your diet checked out,
getting,
you know,
getting your blood work done,
finding out where your nutritional levels are.
Eat like a,
you normally would eat.
Don't try to trick them.
He like you would normally,
oh old about Kale,
bro.
I'm all about organic celery.
But get your,
you know,
go to a reputable place and get your blood work done and find out where your
nutrients are lacking.
It's really important.
A lot of times you think you have a good diet and you're just being naive.
Start looking at your diet and you go,
oh,
I eat a lot of shit.
I never thought I had it.
Good die while you're one up.
They went up on a delusional.
Folks,
I'll have one for four days and I go,
now I deserve to eat a whole pot or something terrible.
There you go.
See a lot of wooden bed.
Um,
so the warrior bars,
uh,
what we were talking about,
so take that into consideration.
But they do have a,
are 140 calories,
a four grams of fat and too uncertain with 14 grams of protein,
which is a lot.
Yeah,
that's really healthy.
And it's,
um,
it's just natural,
uh,
buffalo with cranberries and,
this,
this ancient recipe that,
uh,
look the code of people,
the Lakota a native Americans used to preserve their buffalo with.
It's delicious.
It tastes good and it's really guilt free.
Um,
as far as like nitrates,
it's salary and salt.
It's a v.
All very good question and I'm going to have to look into that.
I had substance use it.
I would say don't be a pussy.
Don't worry about salary and salt.
[inaudible] worried about salary,
fucking sea salt and salary.
If those are the two things that are going to take you out in this game,
how weak is your defense son?
How weak?
Um,
we sell a lot of shit on it that we find,
uh,
you can find other places.
Uh,
but what we tried to do is just get the,
the best versions of it available,
like hemp force,
protein powders.
Uh,
an important one when it comes to that.
You can get hemp protein from other places,
but a lot of times it's super gritty.
Uh,
it's not that easy to digest,
to assist a different texture.
It feels different when you drink it.
Uh,
it's just because it's not the highest quality of the stuff that we buy.
Cost more money,
but it's higher in protein and it's,
it's easy to digest.
It's super powdery.
It's really interesting the difference between the hemp force protein powder
and,
uh,
I've used some powders from some other companies that use the cheaper shits,
like just more cores,
more fiber in it.
And it's a,
you know,
it's like you've tasted in your mouth and you're drinking grit.
Uh,
but as far as like the,
your body's ability to digest it,
I think it's the easiest form of protein to digest.
My body has zero problems.
I can,
I can drink a hemp force protein shake with coconut water and work out in like
an hour.
That's never,
I can't do,
there's nothing else I can eat or I can work out in an hour and it can be
comfortable about it because the stuff just digest so easily.
Like I love way.
I'd love like those,
um,
muscle milk's,
those are fucking delicious.
Those tastes good.
But my body does not react that well to that stuff.
Like,
you know,
what was the difference you notice between muscle milk and the hemp then?
No farts.
Okay,
let's be real big.
Will make you sick.
Let's get crazy.
I would fart like crazy when I would drink the way pre,
remember Tate's farts.
There's still legendary.
It's all weight.
They smell.
It's all whey protein men.
Um,
but I like it.
I like it.
Whey protein.
I'm not saying it's bad,
but as far as digestibility,
oh,
hemp force is my favorite shit of all time.
Whether I was selling or not,
I would tell you that it's fucking fantastic.
Um,
so that's it.
Go to [inaudible] dot com o n n I t used the Codeword Rogan,
and you can save 10% off any and all supplements and a,
what are the economy dates you've got coming up,
Brian?
Uh,
this weekend we're going to be in Tampa,
Florida,
Meagan,
Sam,
Tripoli.
Uh,
Friday.
It's Tampa.
Saturday,
it's Jacksonville,
and then Sunday is a Orlando.
And you can go to Jess squad.
Dot.
TV for tools or for Laura
and ring penicillins.
But those are the,
that's like Lord,
that's like up higher,
right?
Like those are okay.
You're the craziest.
The craziest of the ones up high.
Really?
Orlando's in the middle.
Yeah.
Orlando is a good spot.
You know what?
But South Florida is fun too,
man.
They're fun.
I enjoy doing shows down there.
People are crazy.
It's a totally different world.
It's a completely different world than the rest of America.
It really is.
Yeah.
South Florida's wild and all the bad ways.
Like Florida,
man.
You follow that Florida man Twitter account?
Yeah.
I mean there's just no denying.
I mean I would,
I would like to have someone like Sam Harris,
some like really rational guy break down
why Florida actually has no more crime.
It's just that for whatever reason people focus on Florida.
But I don't know if that's entirely accurate.
The sheer numbers of idiocy that you get this just a numbers,
a moron to come out of Florida.
It's almost hard to believe,
right?
Watched almost every single episode of Cops and Florida is always the best
episodes.
That's a great show.
By the way.
They should do it as long as they,
they,
they re edited all the old episodes of cops and like made an HD and edit them
real fast and quick now.
So it's called cops reloaded.
It's,
Oh,
I wonder how much they could do just on Florida.
because it picked out from every other,
if you could just have camera's running 24 hours a day and hire some editors,
just keep the cameras on.
You would never go wrong.
I mean Wacky Shit happens in Florida all like if you were a vice cop in Miami
and you had a camera on your car,
like how much?
We don't need to do commercials anymore.
We're here.
Um,
we don't need the music.
Fuck it.
Um,
but if you are a vice cop and you were in Miami and they just put a camera on
your head,
how much wacky shit would you see every year?
Probably be madness.
Oh,
every,
I mean it would be every other day there'd be something amazing,
crazy.
Like everyone should just have a GoPro on their head and just be traveling.
And I do
know,
and a lot of states they said that's lowered the instances of police harassment
or police brutality substantially.
And I know,
I believe Los Angeles has some,
some sort of program,
at least on some of the officers where they put these cameras on them.
You know,
we're starting to see so much video of cops beating people up,
man.
It's really disturbed.
It is.
It's so disturbing.
Like that one cop that beat that lady up on the side of the freeway,
it was seen that one.
Fuck,
Holy Shit.
She might've been mentally challenged and she was acting like she was walking in
the on the freeway.
I don't know what her deal was.
I don't know.
But if that is the only way that he can control her,
she shouldn't be a cop.
Like you can't just fucking waylay somebody in the face over and over again
while you're holding on to their neck on the side of the highway.
You just can't do that.
That's,
that's not defensive.
You're not like,
you're not saving them from themselves.
You're not saving anybody from the,
you're assaulting them.
You know,
like you should be able to contain that woman.
A woman wasn't as striking him at all.
If you had any,
you know,
knowledge of Jujitsu whatsoever,
you would just contain her.
It'd be really easy to do.
I mean,
you might get hit with some clawing at you and shit,
but you could hold her in place and nobody has to get hurt if you're a cop.
It's not like that woman was attacking him.
You know,
if that one was attacking him,
like say if that woman had a bat or a knife or something and she's coming at him
and he took her down and punch her in the face,
I'm all for that.
That's a Dane.
That might as well be an animal.
A person that's attacking you with a weapon.
Might as well be an animal.
That's how I feel like if would you kick a dog that tried to bite you?
Fuck yeah.
A with a knife that's coming at you.
It doesn't matter if it's a man or a woman.
They're getting punched in their fucking face for real.
Right.
It Ha you have to.
Otherwise you're a dead man Brian.
Yes.
Is running an option cause I'd like to just run away.
Yeah,
you could run faster.
Definitely do.
Okay,
cool.
I'll do that.
Side to side.
If you've got a good Juke,
but at the end of the day,
like if you're a cop,
you can't just beat somebody up like that.
You just can't do that.
Like,
that lady's not hitting you like you,
like she's,
which wouldn't listen like what's going on?
Like there's no way she could've been doing anything that's that justified
getting a fuck beat out of her life.
Isn't there like some police force that's now putting Gopros on all the cops?
Like they,
their whole forest.
You have to have like a GoPro camera on your person now.
We should probably Google.
He keeps saying,
I just heard it.
The,
it'd be great.
Yeah,
that makes so much more sense.
I don't know.
And would,
would it would,
it should be something that broadcasts.
Yeah,
that'd be cool.
because subscribed to that would be the best cops by the way.
Ever,
ever.
You go home.
I want to see what's going on in my hometown cops.
You could just stream it Compton really low.
It's pretty bad.
Cops use go pros to film traffic.
Stop.
Oh,
this is different.
I think it was Florida actually,
that now that I think about it.
That was doing it.
Florida police camera.
Look at this.
Uh,
copies is a Gopro to film a traffic stop of a lieutenant cop.
Miami police officer,
he made a routine traffic stop.
He discovered that it's a man of superior rank,
like a cop that superior ranked him.
They start fighting and he got suspended.
Yeah,
I saw that.
And the lieutenant is merely reassigned,
huh?
Yeah,
he filmed the whole thing too.
And this,
the hierarchy,
like that's like a weird thing to rank thing for police officers.
Like that's some military shit.
Like the whole rank thing like that.
He had to like,
you know,
give in to a superior officer.
Like that's what the issue is.
A superior rank.
How weird is that?
Like a guide
general or the person ran a red light,
like let's calm down.
I mean,
I guess
cops should be able to get better positions as they get better at their job and
they should get more prestige as they get more experience and knowledge officer
went out to California now required to wear video cameras while on,
see it's right in the middle and it says,
just like full on Gopro that just records every time.
One year use
of force of drops,
60% complaints have dropped 88%.
Wow.
Holy Shit.
That's accountability,
man.
Yeah,
it's all about accountability.
That's exactly what that is.
You know,
it's not that,
that's being a cop is a tricky decision to be the guy who decides how things get
handled and times of stress.
And that's your job.
You do that every day.
You come in,
people are screaming,
wives and husbands,
are you worried you're going to get shot?
Like they're always worried they're going to get shot.
Like domestic violence cases especially,
he imagined,
I have anything to do with these crazy people,
but the neighbors' lights are all on,
it's five o'clock in the morning,
people are screaming,
they're throwing shit and you know,
you're,
you hear the guy say I'm gonna fucking kill you and you're outside and you're a
cop and you're like,
Jesus Christ here.
We got like that's your job.
That's cool.
That's a crazy job.
It's hard for anybody,
I think to expect that people that go through that job on a daily basis or
perfect or they should be held to the same standards as everybody else as far as
like their ability to tolerate bullshit cause they get,
they see too much.
Yeah,
that's a crazy job.
It's crazy job.
And so you know when people look at pro police brutality,
you got to look at the cops too.
Like what are these guys being subjected to?
It's not just that these cops are lashing out and attacking people.
It's like what's making them ramp up their,
their violence.
So they just inherently violent.
That's a real convenient way to look at it,
to just decide they're just inherently violent and that they're assholes and
bullies and that's why they became cops in the first place.
And that might be correct for some,
but you also got to take into consideration what they're seeing on a daily
basis.
Their fucking job is to deal with the worst situations that people have to see
every day,
every day.
Bullets,
car accidents,
motorcycle wreck,
violence,
murder,
suicide.
Yeah,
the worst parts of humanity.
All the worst liars,
liars,
thieves,
rapists,
all day.
It's got to be overwhelming.
And then for them to be,
you know,
in a situation with a person and the person is like,
y'all don't have to listen to you.
Oh you don't,
you fucking pitch.
He's like,
they're so wound up,
they're always at like eight.
You know,
if you live in that world and you're constantly like dodging this and evading
that and capturing this guy and pulling that guy off the street and fuck man,
what,
it's why it surprises me when when you see cops that are so young,
when there's like a 21 year old,
22 year old cop and you're like,
that guy is going to be able to handle all this stress.
Like the domestic violence thing.
Like he'd show up to a house,
husband and wife are arguing and it's like that kids probably had sex twice and
he's supposed to like know what to do during a,
yeah.
I wonder if they have people that they specifically assigned to those kinds of
cases that are like good at that shit.
Okay.
Yeah.
Does that make sense?
But I would,
that's like an Al Pachino role and heat.
No,
I'm in,
can I talk to you?
You know,
get,
get the guy to the window and put the gun down.
Norman.
You know there's a lot of cops here.
You know,
it'd be like the guy who likes slowly talk to you off the ledge.
I bet in real life cop world though,
it's like what is it is a murder.
There's no specialists.
Like,
dude,
I don't even do robbery.
I'm not doing robbery.
I'm over here.
I'm doing violent crime.
Yeah.
Not Nothing petty.
I know they're cops.
They show up where this,
you know,
there's like vice departments,
right?
And they have like different departments,
but for the most part they all deal with bullshit.
That's what they do.
Hold closer to the crime,
just get there and deal with it.
Deal with nonsense all day,
deal with the worst of us.
And every time they talk to people that people are lying.
Like most of the time,
most of the time people were talking to cops.
They're lying.
Yeah.
I don't think I've ever talked to a cop when it hasn't been like I'm on the end
of getting in trouble and I'm like,
how do I get out of it?
I've never just been like,
hey officer,
nice,
nice to see it today.
I've never done that.
That's funny.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people's interaction with cops on the street,
man.
That's a lot of people's,
uh,
if you think about it,
remember that video that kid was taking a video of the woman was beaten him up
and uh,
she was,
uh,
she was screaming,
you know,
at him and he was like,
stop hitting me please.
Dot.
And it's all he was doing and she was saying that she was going to say that he
sexually assaulted her.
Yeah.
Remember they,
the other one that we showed that,
that uh,
that the old women's stealing the guys stuff,
they've,
that reddit guys at reddit found her name and her Facebook and from when it
started going to her page,
and it's ridiculous because he's like,
it looks like she's just a normal woman that just happened to be like stealing
shit.
What do you know what?
That's a weird thing about people's looks.
There's like some sweetie pie look and people that are killer Ted Bundy.
Perfect example.
Yeah,
yeah.
I've met like,
uh,
there's a lot of MMA guys like that too.
Like you would never know Jujitsu guys.
There's a lot of Jujitsu guys.
Like you would never know.
You look at them,
they just look like normal dudes and they would,
they could kill people and it's just like there's something about their head
like they ha it's not just their physical abilities,
it's like their head,
they have like little,
little something extra,
a little piece of wood,
but they look like,
you know,
oop.
You know,
it's like all American boy,
I'm click a total normal sweet faced fella,
you know,
meanwhile they're just stone cold killers.
Some old lady could be a dirty murderer.
Know you're looking at her on the beach and she's like someone's grammy.
Like where's your grandparents?
Oh they're over there by that tent.
Oh,
hi grammy.
And that's her.
Meanwhile she's a dirty stinky thief stealing someone's tent,
packing it up.
And then she's done it before obviously.
Cause then that guy came up to her.
She wasn't surprised,
you know,
she was like playing it off like what this is ours.
I'm pretty sure this is ours.
This is our stuff.
Fucking,
I mean,
you know,
it had been,
it was a complicated tent.
They got like fucking posts and Shit and they're folded everything up and put it
in bags and stuff and it's all dirty broads.
Just stealing shit
probably has gotten away with that for the last 15 years.
Yeah.
After you hit a certain age,
no one suspects you right.
That's an innocent old person's not going
to steal anything.
Well,
people become dose and they don't even know why.
Like I had a girl that I was dating when when I was in high school that had a
bit of an issue at one point in time.
And she was a very good person.
She went a bad person at all.
She's not like a bad kid from a bad home,
but she wanted something and she didn't have the money and she just took it,
you know?
And it was just this thing where like she did it a couple of times and she got
in trouble for it.
She didn't get arrested but she got caught.
She would give the stuff back.
I don't remember.
It wasn't,
wasn't anything monumental,
but it was enough where she was trying to understand why she was doing this.
Like I can't,
I almost can't stop.
Like I go in the store and there's something I want and I know no one's looking.
I figured out a way to get it and I'm like that.
That's crazy.
Like that stealing.
But she is,
it was like when they say Kleptomania like for some folks it really is an issue.
Like they really can get obsessed with this idea of stealing something and they
can't help.
It
shall ideas.
He has to do it all the allegedly all the time at the,
I like the airport would just be like,
he would just be stuffing hamburgers in his pockets and you're just like,
what the fuck are you worried about this Brian?
Or he'll just go and get to one of those little stands where they have like
drinks and popcorn and stuff and he's just putting stuff in his pockets like
right in the open,
like not because it's about the thrill.
It's not even like,
oh I need this thing.
Is it like the adrenaline?
Can I get away with it?
Let's
say this about Joey,
that was a long time ago and he's a different guy.
No role at all anymore,
right?
I don't know.
You know,
the girl was 17 at the time.
Um,
and like I said,
she's not a bad person by any stretch of the imagination.
She's very nice.
She's very smart too.
She just had a thing and that thing was she wanted to steal shit.
And I don't think,
you know,
it could be a combination.
First of all,
when you're 17,
you're essentially insane,
you know,
I mean,
you really are not sure what's going on for the last couple of years.
Your body's been overwhelmed with hormones and you're like,
what is that?
Like,
why do I feel so different than I did,
you know,
just two or three years ago.
And you're obsessed with girls,
right?
And girls are obsessed with boys and so you've just start fooling around having
sex and it becomes like your whole life becomes obsessive when you're young and
you're about to become an adult and you're going to have to take care of
yourself.
And you're like,
what?
Nobody taught me shit.
I just want to fuck all the dumb 17 I'm almost 18 then I got to fend for myself,
you know,
and then graduations out and you take your deep breath and you try to figure it
out.
Like wow,
what next?
They're all crazy.
Everyone that age is crazy.
So some of them steal clothes and some of them sniff paint and some of them,
you know,
whatever become cops that beat people.
That's a little harder than you can't be more than 17 how old do you have to be
to be a cop?
Alright.
I think,
I think
ACP 14 if you can join the military,
yeah,
she'll be 40 she'll be 40 year old dudes are yoked.
They're like hiring and Burbank cops right now.
There's signs everywhere that says now hiring.
I'm sure it's probably a tough job.
It's probably tough to get people to do because uh,
you know,
I don't think most of us have the perspective to understand what they have to go
through.
So I think a lot of people also treat cops would like to stains kind of cool to
treat cops with disdain,
but that's all well and good.
But if the shit hit the fan,
you'd be fucking happy they were cops.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I remember that.
North Hollywood shootout.
Remember that shit?
Oh yeah.
With the autumn,
fully automatic weapons.
Do you remember that Brian?
Like video game,
dude,
we were on a news radio was on the set of news radio and I forget who told us it
was happening,
but we all gathered up in this break room to watch this and we were watching
this on a TV,
someone's office or something.
I remember where we were watching.
We were like,
this is fucking crazy.
Like we were all holding our hands in our heads.
Like,
what are we looking at?
This dude's arm to the tits.
He's got a,
you showing it,
pull it up on the screen so we can see it too.
This dude is armed to the tits.
He's got bulletproof everything on.
They got a van stuffed with bullets and Ammo and rifles and shit and he's just
fucking cops up.
This is a different guy,
Brian,
isn't it?
The North Hollywood shootout is what you want.
Is this it?
Yeah.
It says North Hollywood shit.
Oh this is the end.
There's,
that's where they just shot him.
This is the end when there was some there some videos before of him like fully
armed up giant machine guns and shit shooting at cops and the cops had pistols.
Bullets are bouncing off of him.
Yeah.
I mean the cops had like standard,
you know,
officer issue pistols and this fucking guy had like the craziest rifles.
Money can buy machine guns and shit and just these two dudes have all these cops
at bay.
This is the same one where they were trying to rob a bank,
right?
That's that one.
Yeah.
Yup.
But see if it was a for cops,
then what?
Those guys do that again next week and they do it again the week after and then
who stops him?
Who stops him?
Yeah.
We would not be able to start to go in house to have,
I'd like,
I have an iPhone I can throw at you or do you do?
If someone's that crazy that they're willing to do something like that,
who knows where that guy's limits are?
That guy could easily just go door to door and gun people down and how many
funny recess.
Yeah.
That are willing.
Imagine if it was a hundred of those guys.
Yes,
exactly.
Out in the street.
Exactly.
That's what you've got to really worry about.
We got really worried about is people that don't think you need a military or
don't think you need law enforcement.
You're really kind of underestimating the evil that human beings are capable of.
We've just been in a nice place here in America for a few hundred years.
Pretty sweet.
As far as world history goes,
like it's invading violence.
Pretty sweet.
Like one of the best spots ever.
Like a solid 200 plus years have nobody coming
over here and fucking us up like a few little baby attacks,
but nothing in comparison to anything that any other empire had to go through
over like you know the course of its,
it's rain now.
If you think about how many like human beings,
how many different countries they are in this country and then that we have
military bases and like a hundred plus of those countries.
You know those numbers are crazy.
That's just stopping and thinking about how many of us there are is nuts,
but if there wasn't a military and so crazy fucks like those north Hollywood
guys gathered up together and decided to start taking shit over,
what would you do?
People are capable of that.
That's,
it's a very unfortunate,
but it's a realistic aspect I could to realistic subject.
It needs to be breached.
It's very unfortunate that people are capable of things like that,
but they are and to not plan on it and to not be prepared in case it happens.
There's a lot of civilizations that don't exist anymore because of that.
Yeah.
You,
you get used to the safety you have.
Then you go to like you know,
a third world country and you're like,
oh,
things aren't as together over there.
And there's like groups of people who are fighting other groups within like that
could never happen here unless they got on the phone going at each other
unless they got over here.
See anything can happen here.
Once it happens here,
you know,
how,
how quickly would they be able to tighten it down?
I don't know.
I would hope quickly,
I would hope quickly.
But like when,
when people look at things like
when you,
when you look at things like the bad aspects of,
um,
of the military or the bad aspects of war and the bad aspects of police
enforcement,
law enforcement,
the bad aspects of,
you know,
people being horrible and police brutality in those situations.
I think we,
people are tending to go in only one direction with the idea.
Like they're only looking at the violence that these cops are doing to
civilians.
The not looking at like,
what are we asking these people to do?
What are we asking these normal people to do for $40,000 a year and how much of
an assurance do we have that these people are of sound character or they can get
through that Gig.
Yeah.
I know there's some screening processes,
but how thorough is it really and how much do we really know about the impact of
day to day violence,
day to day bullshit that these people have to deal with?
It sounds like the craziest job ever.
Imagine if you had to be a vice cop.
No,
but I would think that I would want that go pro on me.
I had all the time,
so yeah.
Yeah,
I think that would,
I think that's the most important thing for cops nowadays.
I think they need that,
I think.
I think that would be a perfect way to police the police and have helped the
cops at the same time.
Imagine starting in a bad neighborhood to,
I'd want to start in the suburbs.
I want to go to watts.
I'm like,
just let me do a couple of traffic stops before I'm like involved in a shootout.
Right.
There was a guy that I used to do taekwondo with.
He got
reassigned.
He wanted to get reassigned to a more urban area and I go,
why do you want to do that?
It's like there's more action.
I was like,
more action.
Wow,
whoa.
I would want to start off like small town like where there's two cops for the
whole city,
you know?
Yeah.
No,
this dude,
this dude wanted to be with the shit was going down.
He genuinely enjoyed it.
He,
there was a,
he's a,
he's an odd duck.
He was like a,
it's weird sorta hard ass cop guy who uh,
who liked to fight,
but he was really nice guy.
Like as a cop.
He's really nice.
Did they have like a good sense for justice?
He wasn't like a power guy.
He was,
it was weird.
He was a sweet guy,
but it seemed like he would like look forward to someone doing something that he
could correct him on.
You know,
like if you didn't,
if you didn't do anything wrong,
he was like a super nice guy.
But it was weird being friends with this dude while it was like a young
teenager.
Cause I always like thought of cops.
It's like,
Oh shit,
I'm gonna get arrested.
You know,
think of all the people that I knew that were dirt bags like,
ah,
I gotta get Outta here.
There's a cop,
you know?
But he was,
um,
he was older than me,
but it was,
it was a weird sort of a relationship because,
um,
he was older than me,
but I was better at martial arts in him.
So I beat his ass.
But he was a cop and then he'd arrest you.
Well you didn't arrest me,
but you know,
I would like,
I would even take it easy on them sometime in sparring because it was a cop
because I would just think like,
I do not want this dude like developing a grudge,
you know?
Yeah.
Cause people could develop a grudge,
you know?
And especially like the Ma like sparring sessions,
there's,
there's like sparring sessions for striking and then sparring sessions for
grappling sparring sessions for grappling are way safer.
So you can go really,
really go at it hard,
but sparring sessions for,
for striking,
they're really dangerous because if people get knocked out all the time,
so this is like a certain amount of respect that you have to give each other and
you have to not hit each other that hard.
And some guys just don't play by that.
Some guys would just,
it all goes out the window and start winging shots at you.
And next thing you know,
you're in a melee.
Like it happens all the time.
We're a sparring session,
turns into an all out fight.
It happens all the time.
So he don't want to do that with a cop,
you know?
And it's especially a cop that it knows how to fight.
Pretty good to see the John Jones thing.
Yeah,
it was crazy,
man.
Jon Jones and Daniel Cormier had gotten this huge scrap at a press conference.
It was Rick Delaws,
John Jones,
uh,
gotten dangle crummy aids face,
put his forehead on Daniel Cormier forehead.
Daniel called me,
had grabbed John Jones by the neck and pushed him away and John dropped his
belt.
And then it was just bodies colliding.
Wow.
And John,
immediately I cast,
you know,
there's a,
it's a wild scramble,
but John was on top and John was like,
I took you down so quick.
Within seven seconds you were on your back.
And they're like,
oh no.
Like the shit talking,
just escalate it to a totally different level.
And John Jones put out a video that said,
uh,
you,
you suck.
You're so weak.
When I got ahold of you felt so weak.
Like it's really,
and then he deleted the video,
which is really interesting.
See,
this is what happened.
Uh,
poor guy in the middle.
Yeah.
That guy there.
This is just a collide.
Oh my God.
Pile of bodies.
Dan is on vacation.
He wasn't even there.
Yeah.
This can't happen.
I can't do that.
This is real bad for the sport.
It's real bad.
It's real bad for public perception.
It's a,
a weapon to be used against MMA.
You know,
it's unfortunate,
which you've got to have everybody should have is uh,
a no contact policy unless guys agree to hug,
you know,
you agree to shake hands and hug.
You should have a no contact policy and anybody clearly violates that no contact
policy gets fined.
You know that some guys can deal with it that getting in each other's face.
But when you have a situation like this,
you know,
you got to have to have a no contact policy with those guys.
The weigh ins,
they're always doing the foreheads stuff and I get it in people's face that's
like know man.
I think it's ridiculous.
It's ridiculous.
And some of it's gamesmanship,
but it's just so bad for the image of the sport.
Is that starting to happen more often?
No,
it's pretty rare.
It's pretty rare.
But that's a big high profile fight.
I mean like Rhonda Rousey and me should,
they got head to head and each of those phases and it was,
it was pretty hot,
I saw were there.
But um,
they were professional about it.
They didn't do anything about it.
These guys were not professional.
Like it was like immediate.
Yeah,
you can't do that.
You know,
he can't grab each other and fucking slap,
you know?
And if you say,
Hey,
I don't want to head but you man,
you know,
or,
but nobody wants to give ground,
you know,
they just,
they don't,
you know,
they don't want anybody getting any psychological advantage and so they're
there.
They have to show each other like they'll fuck,
I'll fucking fight you right here.
And then you know,
that's when shit like this happens.
It's like they just have to treat it.
You got,
this is a,
like the importance of that not happening is huge to huge.
There's a,
it's just such a negative connotation attached to what that is.
That's just violence.
The difference between that kind of violence and the violence of a sport is the
violence of a sport is everyone's agreeing to this scenario.
You're agreeing to train for x amount of weeks.
You're going to fight for x amount of rounds.
You're going to fight this guy.
He weighs what you weigh.
Everybody prepares,
you meet at this day and you compete.
And it's a very dangerous form of competition.
And yes,
it is fighting as a competition,
but it's not violence the same way that that is.
That's a street fight.
That's okay.
That's a world champion.
Mixed martial arts fighter and an Olympic wrestler and there's street fighting.
That's bad for everybody.
That's bad for wrestling.
That's bad for MMA.
That's bad for sports.
It's fun for people to watch,
you know.
Oh yeah,
you know,
was part of me.
I have two,
two ways of looking at it.
Part of is like that's bad for the sport,
but pardon me is like how do I feel about it though?
Does it bum me out?
No,
no.
It doesn't make me upset.
I'm not upset.
I'm looking forward to watching this fight even more now.
Look,
I would,
I have liked it to non happen.
Absolutely.
I wish that they were very professional about this.
They don't need to do that.
That fight is going to be amazing no matter what happens.
But since it did happen and I got to see it,
I'm like,
Whoa,
I'm not going to pretend that that's not fun.
You know,
I'm not going to pretend that that didn't make everybody way more excited about
that fight cause it fucking for sure did.
Yeah,
it's not good.
It's not good to do,
but it was fun to watch and more people are going to be excited about the fight.
I mean there's,
that's the catch 22 that's,
there's no real black or white about this,
you know,
as a representative of the sport.
I absolutely wish it didn't happen as a,
a person who cares a lot about the future of the sport and the public's
perception,
which I think is already a little skewed.
I think there's a lot of people that aren't fans that like to look at the people
that fight in him MMA.
It's just barbarians.
But there's a,
there was a lot of Nice guys that fight in the UFC and there are some of the
nicest athletes you'll ever meet.
That's a fact.
So pardon me.
He gets bummed out when I see shit like that,
but part of me is like,
look,
they're going to fight eventually anyway.
A little here.
Being passionate,
a little taste,
get a little taste.
I Dunno.
It's going to be a wild ass fight though.
When is that fight?
That's a good question.
Um,
it's uh,
I think it's September 27th in Vegas.
Is that it or is the weekend of the 27th,
uh,
either way it's on like donkey Kong.
No,
it's going to be exciting,
but it's unfortunate man.
It's unfortunate.
So as far as now they didn't get in any trouble.
I Dunno.
I mean is on vacation.
I mean I read that that there is that they were going to get in trouble.
There's some thing in that contract,
you know that you can't do that shit.
No
thing that says there'll be consequences.
That's the statement.
The official statement.
There will be consequences.
It's almost scary or that was,
yeah,
that sounds very little.
Contact you.
It's very vampire.
Like it'd be consequences to actions.
You don't get any of the headphones to wear during the fights.
Have you been watching the strain?
You've been watching the strain
del Toro show on Fx.
It's fucking great man.
It's great.
I'm just waiting now.
But wait until these five or six there.
Yeah,
there's four out now.
This is the fourth one just aired on Sunday.
It's fucking fun.
Cause the billboard with the thing going into the,
I was like,
I'm in,
I don't even know what this says,
but I'm absolutely doing this.
I read the
book and I don't remember the worms from the book.
Maybe I just don't remember.
Maybe I have to go back and read it again.
I didn't remember that part.
But I remember the book being really entertaining for like three quarters away
through like really fun in the beginning too.
It's a story.
It's a,
it's an interesting story and they don't a great job at the,
uh,
the miniseries.
It's really good man.
It's like really ropes you in.
It's fun.
And he tried.
I just gave up on the leftovers.
I love horror movies and shows like we need more of that shit.
Like more,
more Zombie Shit.
More uh,
you know,
more vampire shit.
It's fun.
Harm or harm.
Movies have taken a big dive.
I don't know if you go back to like the 1950s,
look at those black and white movies at which super popular back then there was
so many horror movies,
man,
the creature from the black lagoon,
remember those.
But now I like now there the demand is so much more for like there to be a real
story and said,
I like this monster attacks avail and then a hot girl gets her clothes ripped
off and you see your tits.
You're like,
that was an amazing dude.
We should do a mystery science theater type thing where we watched creature from
the black of good.
It is.
So first of all,
it's so obvious during a swimming pool.
He's not a fucking lagoon at all.
It was like some back lot swimming pool.
They put cement there.
That's weird.
The fucking,
the creature was pretty dope for the time.
It was like just a really cool scuba diving outfit.
Essentially.
This,
this weird freaky lizard like scuba diving outfit.
They put this,
this guy in and he would swim in the swimming pool at capture that girl.
It's so bad.
It's so bad that it's awesome.
Like it's so bad.
It's exciting when you watch it.
Here it is
out of the mom and this 300 million years ago,
depths,
Avanti known water comes up creature to confound science and terrorize the
world.
This is awesome.
Grab this guy by the head.
It was the worst acting job anybody's ever done.
Ever.
Look at this.
Shocking
perfected three dimension.
Ou was three d.
I didn't even know it was three days.
It was one of those where you got your glasses in the Sunday paper and they
would play it on the TV.
Remember that?
Wow.
No,
that's cool.
You'll
find out.
I do remember that.
The bridge between vision from the land down
changed in many of you
here.
Even the music here we have a clue to an answer.
Richard Cow.
Remley.
I'm venturing underwater in the camp of Mit.
I'm on
lovely Julia or beauty,
a law man,
a dawn of time.
Fucking penny.
Who was tying that?
I couldn't burn to them.
The most amazing under one roof brain has ever known.
Wow.
This is incredible.
I look at it,
that's so obvious.
It's a pool.
This is not a ripple in that water.
Look at it for men dead so far.
Staying until we get or until somebody else gets killed
is dives in the water with her
deep,
and do the waters of his domain.
This is hilarious.
He's just going to drown this chick.
I know she wasn't dead already.
What's he doing?
Is he making out with her?
Does she keep her from drowning Rick cave or does she have a scuba outfit?
Amazing.
In three dimension,
quick job from the black lagoon.
They should do it and remake it.
This one guy,
just some monster and a creek.
Scratch all these rapes and then,
yeah,
you could come up with a better story.
Right?
You just say,
it was like some genetic experiment that,
oh,
it's taped some dude who's really rich and Florida from cocaine.
He hired a bunch of scientists,
right.
To try to make lizard soldiers.
Right.
This,
that could totally be a story.
They could do that creature from the black and to be in Miami,
fucking people up in Miami because you need the hot girls to kill.
Yeah.
We're always swimming around.
Well,
you'll,
it needs at least them to run.
You don't have to kill him.
Yeah.
Very slow motion if they're run titties or balancing,
whether being chased by a lizard man.
That's what you could count on with all those Jason Movies where you're like in
the first scene he's going to be walking through some camp and there's going to
be a bunch of girls going like nothing's going to happen cause she's take off
clothes.
It's very hot.
Yeah,
let's make out for warmth.
that does.
Shondra is kind of,
that genre is kind of gone away a bit.
Right.
It,
I mean those were big movies.
Oh I know.
Halloween,
Friday the 13th all those movies.
Those are big movies man.
Like you get fired up Friday 30th Freddy Krueger.
Even when they were bad,
they were good.
Yeah.
There was,
if you could ensure that a couple of girls would be having a pillow fight and it
tit would pop out and the ax murderer shows up.
Yeah.
You're talking about that for two months with your friends if you're a teenager.
Especially if it's like Jason Cause he's,
he's on dead or whatever it is.
Nobody knows what he is.
Yeah.
He was killed and then came back so they fucking run them over.
They shoot him,
rises and somehow or another finds a way to get you
and it didn't even matter back.
Then.
They're like,
well,
we have to explain to the viewers how he came back to like,
well that's what does like four pairs of tits or for immediately there forget.
Then it just goes on a rampage for two hours.
It was a different world back then.
Scream movies were good.
I thought the scream.
Yeah,
those were good.
Those are fun.
It took a lot from those,
that old school of horror slasher
film thing.
What bums me out is the lack of monster movies.
That's a bums me out.
Like whenever a good monster movie comes out,
I get like super excited.
I,
this is going to be fun,
but there's so few.
So few like Godzilla is our right,
you know,
it was fun.
It was.
It was really well done.
Like the gods ill itself is amazing,
but there,
this is just one motherfucker.
The main dude who survives more close calls,
this goddamn movie than anybody in the history of monster movies.
I mean,
it's so ridiculous.
Like everywhere he is,
everybody dies and he escapes and everybody dies and he escapes and everybody
does it.
He's like,
fuck man.
You know that by the time the movie's over,
by the end of the movie,
like you used up all your get out of jail free cards,
dude,
like yeah,
you just officially ridiculous.
Like he's the guy that lands in between the pause,
the tail slams,
and it's like,
Oh God,
I was like four feet away.
Thank God.
Exactly.
I mean it's just,
there's so many cut the shit scenes,
but what they can do now as far as the special effects,
it makes it worth,
it makes it worth seeing because even if the story is goofy as Shit,
the monsters are insane.
Like,
good,
wait God,
Zillow looks now.
Holy Fuck didn't did you.
You watched it and didn't like it.
It was that you,
I never saw it.
Or Ari,
Ari was like,
yeah,
he hated it.
Of course he did.
He's like,
ah,
totally.
Don't watch that movie ever,
like what's wrong?
And he just had all these problems with the storyline.
I'm like,
Ra,
it's a giant lizard destroying Japan or whatever it might be.
A God.
Yeah.
They always do that.
And he's movies in my pit.
God dumped them.
Yeah,
they might be gods.
What was the one with the giant robot warrior ones that came out?
Oh,
transformers.
No,
no,
it was um,
oh,
I liked that one.
She really giant robots going at it.
It was like watching a video game.
It was cool.
That part was cool.
But the,
the uh,
the,
the human parts were portable and it really felt like I was watching someone
like took a comic book and just didn't do any rewrites it all and just slapped
it together.
It was very comic book live,
which is,
you know,
I think in some cases is fine,
but the comic books that they're doing,
not comic book movies,
they do so well.
Like captain America,
you know,
it's silly story,
but it's a good,
they do a really good job.
Like they make these movies are fun to watch.
They do a great job.
So like if you go back to like really clunky sort of like stuff like that,
like the,
the Pacific thing,
it just,
it's just,
it was too clunky for me.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
Store like storywise yeah.
That I didn't even,
I was like,
I want to go watch a movie and turned my brain off.
And I'm like,
what better thing to watch?
Like 200 foot tall robots destroy each other.
But there was a seam in this like guy and a grower in love with each other or
something.
And I was like,
what am I watching here?
What kind of,
yeah.
That's where you're like,
oh,
bathroom time or cigarette or something.
What is this robot
fight thing?
What are you guys doing?
What's happening here?
Where's the monsters?
Yeah,
show me some monsters,
bitch.
I hated the acting.
I,
I was,
I couldn't even watch it.
Yeah,
but seems like they,
it was a choice though.
It seemed very comic book like right.
Didn't it?
Almost like they were going for like a certain,
a certain feel.
Yeah.
How did that like comic book video game feel exactly like,
I don't even remember who was in it.
Not The human beings that were in it.
Yeah.
I remember I got really mad when I finally watched that movie because everyone
told me it was good.
That fucking Tom Cruise movies.
Good.
The the latest one.
Yeah,
the edge of tomorrow.
What's that one about?
It's a science fiction movie.
It's really good,
man.
It's really good.
I mean I said it's really good and a bunch of people criticized me online.
How dare you.
But I think that those people you to movie sucks.
Listen man,
it's just my taste.
Okay.
You can't say it sucks.
I liked,
we liked different things,
but uh,
I understand if you think the movie sucks to you,
but to me I thought it was excellent it,
and if it wasn't Tom Cruise,
I think if it was some other dude that didn't carry a lot of baggage,
I think it'd probably been braided a lot higher than it was.
I think one of the reasons why people are like,
Oh,
the movie wasn't that good.
I really think it's because it's a Tom cruise movie.
I think like Tom Cruise is moving movies.
People think they're good,
they're pretty good.
That's pretty good.
But if it was like another actor in the same role,
like they wouldn't,
it wouldn't be judged the same way I think.
I think people just think that guy is so wacky.
Yeah.
It's reputation proceeds.
Anything else they can do from now on?
He,
but he's,
he's so,
so good.
It's like he's really good actor.
He's fucking really good in this movie.
Like you buy it like a,
I don't want to give away the plot,
but it's a,
it's a pretty ridiculous plot and he sells it.
Like the idea behind it is pretty crazy and he sells it.
It people moving.
People forget like there's a reason he became the biggest movie star in the
world.
Yeah.
It's cute.
It's got a cute face.
Yeah.
It's,
he's talented.
He's talented as fuck.
Just happens to be insane.
Yeah.
I think that everybody who's really good at that Gig is insane.
I think that's an insane person's hobby or insane person's profession.
Yeah,
they're really good ones.
I mean you can contain your insanity,
but
that's like the difficult trick it seems for celebrities now is to not let it
out crazy.
Cause there's so many.
Then you could just like,
oh I'm going to tweet something.
And people were like,
dude,
you know Sheil a buff is out of his mouth.
Did you read all those tweets?
And it was,
that's all been there.
We just didn't know.
Like imagine if there were social media and the fifties that did things.
Humphrey Bogart railing against.
Yeah.
Cary grant's like homophobic.
I didn't know all the,
the racist shit that would be sad.
All the Duis that would be publicized,
the all the domestic and be like,
who knows what those people were in two back then.
What is that guy's name
from the early 19 hundreds?
Fatty Arbuckle.
Yeah.
Remember that whole story?
No Fatty Arbuckle apparently.
Um,
they put up a bottle or a glass up a woman's vagina and it killed her.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Something.
Ha,
let me,
let me pull it up.
Fatty.
And he was,
uh,
he was acquitted but he never worked again.
Wow.
What's that James?
Up on the screen.
Right.
Fatty Arbuckle.
His name is Roscoe Roscoe Arbuckle.
Yeah.
Um,
he uh,
yeah,
the woman died four days later.
She fallen ill at a party and she died.
Whoa.
He was accused by,
um,
this woman's a acquaintance of accidentally killing the woman and after the
first two trials,
which resulted in hung juries,
Arbuckle was acquitted in the third trial and received a formal written apology
from the jury.
Despite Arbuckle's acquittal,
the scandal has most overshadow,
mostly overshadowed his legacy as a pioneering comedian falling the trials,
his films where banned and he was publicly ostracized,
although the ban and his films was lifted within a year.
Our buckle only works sparingly through the 1920s.
He later worked as a film director under the alias William Goodrich.
He was finally able to return to acting,
making two short real comedies in 1932 for Warner brothers.
He died and they sleep of a heart attack at the age of 46.
Whoa.
Reportedly on the same day,
sign a contract with Warner brothers to make a feature film.
That's scary.
Shit.
It doesn't say here what he did,
like it doesn't get into graphic detail about it.
Okay.
Just said she had fallen ill.
I don't know.
Yeah.
I wonder if they,
how old is that story?
Um,
it's from 1921.
Yeah,
I guess I don't,
I doubt they printed stuff like that back then.
Yeah.
Like anything that alluded to sexual whatever,
it's like,
no,
she was ill,
but they wouldn't even use the word pregnant.
They'd be like expecting,
and they're saying that he wasn't that big,
but what,
what the charge was that he had killed her with his weight while savagely raping
her.
It says that the newspapers of the day reveled in the glory rumor details.
Juries found little evidence that Arbuckle wasn't any way connected with her
death.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Imagine how many more of those stories about those like old legends that were
like considered pristine stars.
And if there was a TMZ back then.
Yeah,
there's two,
there's a couple of different versions.
Like his,
they,
this one website has,
um,
one person's version and then the fatty Arbuckle vars,
they're two different versions of what exactly happened.
You know Boyan on my friend.
That's fucked.
Yeah.
How did we get on the subject of Fatty Arbuckle?
Oh,
it's because Tom Cruise is considered crazy.
Like they probably were a bunch of crazy.
There's always been crazy celebrity.
That's why it was crazy.
Everything.
People are crazy.
It's just that people done a really good job of hiding their crazy until they
shut their doors.
They would get home.
Can I take care of it by shut that door and
put up a
ball gag in place.
Yeah.
Go down there
basement.
Fucking chain themselves up.
Yeah.
People are crazy.
We're starting to see it.
It's coming out more.
It's going to be great when people want to go back to privacy,
when they want to cherish their privacy,
it's not going to happen.
He'd have to go somewhere like the big island of Hawaii.
No Internet.
There's no internet.
No.
I mean you could,
you would live there with no internet.
Oh,
okay.
And there is Internet in the big islands.
Great.
But if you really want to,
first of all,
think about the fact that there's Internet on the big,
I don't fucking Hawaii,
it takes five hours to get there on a plane.
Right?
You fly through the air for five hours and someone laid fiber across the ocean
floor.
That is that length.
I mean that's how it works,
right?
I think so.
I have no idea.
Isn't that how it works?
Like there has to be a direct line.
Some under water lines.
There's underwater line son.
How exactly,
how did they do that?
The Pacific Ocean.
So they just like were tossing this in there and let's help like a shark doesn't
non,
okay,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna Google.
How do they get Internet in Hawaii
called AOL?
Dude,
it's one.
It's one of the first things that people ask.
Let's see what they say.
How does it,
why yet?
Internet,
Yahoo Answers.
The unit is provided via a 10,000 miles sub marine and terrestrial fiber optic
cable connecting the state.
Six major islands,
which is owned and operated by Pacific light net.
Wow.
10,000 miles,
dude.
So there are like cables connecting all the continence.
Yup.
That's how,
yeah,
that's crazy.
And if you think about that,
like what part of that?
Most people don't know like that,
that part we don't know.
Like most people aren't like wait a minute.
It's all a why there's wires everywhere.
People don't think of that.
You don't think of that?
Like you don't think there's like a wire that goes across the ocean to England
and that's how he's doing the inner signals flying through the air.
The people building railroads were like this is impressive.
We link this city,
that one with all this steel.
Right.
And now it's like there's a cable where I can just like pick up a thing and send
a thing.
Yeah.
And just type of thing and watch a video.
Screw you.
Train two weeks.
That is why he gets really squirrely when people start talking about like,
um,
when you start talking about like videos that you can and can't watch and other
countries like why can't I watch this in South Africa?
Like,
why can't how come this is is because the pipe,
like they don't have agreement with various pipes.
Yeah.
I mean that must be it.
Right?
Music licensing also mostly and things like that.
Yeah.
Music licensing and I'm sure all
so like that there are certain places like they don't want to waste their
bandwidth on a product that's not available in your country.
I'm surprised terrorist is,
I haven't gotten after these lines.
Yeah.
That seems like
why are you giving them great ideas,
bro?
Just gave it away.
Oh my God.
You're so bad for America.
Allocate is building a submarine to go down anymore.
It's Isis.
You got to keep up on your bad guys.
I didn't,
they change it from Isis again.
I do not know.
Well,
if they were smart,
they would since I know about it.
Right.
Yeah.
I would say once I know about your organization,
it's no longer secret.
You know,
I need to,
I mean,
I made a mistake on the last episode I was on when I saw the video of a Israeli,
uh,
hitting a Powerade stining and kid.
Remember that when I was talking about the Gig,
I guess there's just a lot of videos that they're just saying they're Israelian
and they're not,
they're just trying like there's people,
yeah.
That,
that was a real video,
but it was,
um,
two other,
uh,
Arab kids.
Yeah.
It wasn't Israeli and so all these people,
angry Jews got on my case.
Well,
we're sorry,
angry you.
He's
angry juice.
Sweeties
but uh,
I think there's some sort of a cease fire right now.
Right.
It's not the idea
that's
unless it's already ended
magic.
We were going to war with Mexico.
Better not,
but think about it like that's essentially what's going on.
Like if where,
where you look at where Israel is and you look at Gaza,
if that we were going to war with Mexico,
that would be what it would be like,
like us going back and forth and rockets from Mexico flying into San Antonio and
we're like,
what the fuck?
Right.
That's real.
Like that's really what it would be like.
Yeah.
Like they would like destroy a seven 11 and El Paso and then we would just like
bomb all of Mexico City for like three straight days.
But that's why the people in Israel,
one of the things about people in Israel is those motherfuckers love to party.
Yeah.
I had a friend,
it was a kickboxing instructor.
I went over his house once for dinner and a dude is playing the bongos and his
wife,
his dancing,
his kids were dancing and they were all cooking.
And I was like,
wow,
this is crazy.
And uh,
he's like a,
this is,
you know how we do it in Israel?
He goes,
you never know.
One day you die,
you know.
So today when we lie party,
party,
party and it was like playing the Bongo drums and all happy,
I was like,
wow,
that's a perspective you only get when you've,
you've been involved in that,
that sort of hellish existence.
Like he,
I believe he was in the military for the Israeli army.
I think it's mandatory actually for everyone.
But,
uh,
you know,
and he was a,
he's an interesting guy,
but always like big smile on his face and very happy.
And that was his explanation.
I go,
well,
you know,
how come you guys are always so happy when I meet someone who's that like
exuberant?
That was his explanation.
You never know.
You know,
you're over there.
It's just like death,
like bombings.
Something always terrible.
You never know.
Everyone could die.
So she'll see Heidi.
Patty had different life with like Israelis and Palestinians are cause it's like
there's no way the Palestinians are partying like that.
That's a good point.
I think they'd party twice as hard.
Let's look.
We're really living under like at any moment.
Yeah.
That's a dark situation,
man.
It really is.
It's very dark.
Like I asked my parents,
they're from Lebanon,
my parents,
it's like they grew up in,
around all that.
You know,
they were like Christian,
you know,
so they,
they just got out of there.
They're like,
we need to get out of here.
But every time I'd ask them about it,
they would just like,
I'm like,
what do you think about what's going on in Israel and Gaza now?
All this stuff.
And they just look at me like,
what do you mean and mean?
What do you think's going to happen?
And they're like,
the same thing that's always going to happen is they're going to keep fighting
and it's never going to end.
But they just look at it like it's not even worth talking about.
I said,
yeah,
it's really like dark and you're just like,
good Lord.
Like they just got so used to it like growing up that like war is a thing.
Like I went to Lebanon when I was 13 I took a v like go back to the homeland
kind of thing.
And like you're in the southern parts of the country and,
and I'd never seen anything like this growing up in the suburbs of La.
But like you're sitting in a village and then there's like a guy tending like
cattle,
there's like goats.
And then five minutes later a tank just drives through a dirt road in the
village.
No one bats an eye,
no one.
But meanwhile I'm like,
you know,
just pointing.
I'm like that's it.
Tank.
And they're like,
yeah that happens like two,
three times a day.
Like Israeli tanks and Lebanese tanks and there's soldiers with fully automatic
weapons walking through towns and that's just like a normal part of life.
Well have you ever done a gig that's unlike a military town?
No.
Whenever you do a,
anytime a you're on the road,
like if you're near Camp Pendleton or Fort Bragg or any of these like military
basis.
Like if you have a gig anywhere nearby,
then you hang out there for a day,
you're going to see like military trucks,
you're going to see,
you know,
Cam owed up jeeps and Humvees and all these different troops,
like constantly moving back and forth left and right.
Like if you're close to that,
you see it all the time.
Yeah,
it's weird.
It's weird.
If you're not used to it,
you're like,
wait a minute,
that's a killing machine.
That's what a tank is.
Oh,
it's good for it to do.
It was doing was looking for trouble.
I mean to like find if there is any trouble.
Could you imagine if you saw that tank and then all of a sudden fucking alarms
start going off in the shit starts flying and you're sitting there like real
close this tank.
Well that's getting shot at.
That happened when we were like,
we're slow.
We went to sleep in the village that night.
The night before we went back up to the city in Beirut and like my younger
brother and I just heard these distant like noises and we like ask my mom like
what are those noise?
And she does not a worry.
It's nothing to worry about it.
Then the next day we were like,
so what were those noises like?
You wouldn't tell us.
And she's like,
those were bombs going off like five miles away from us.
Yeah.
So it was like terrorists bombing each other five miles away from us.
Yo.
And you're that 13 year old kid and you're like,
I like grew up in a suburb of La.
It's just,
it couldn't be safer.
Like six cops will pull you over for smoking a cigarette and five miles away.
It's like people are destroying each other.
Wow.
Israel,
it really helped like shaped my perspective of what it,
what it's like to live in America and grow up in America.
Cause I that could have been me like I kind of like live there and maybe who
knows if I would've gotten to age 30,
31,
32 and then,
yeah,
that's absolutely true.
We're all stupid.
Lucky.
Oh yeah.
That we landed on this spot because you get a landed anywhere.
You could be in the Congo right now and go,
oh well how do I get out of this
Bola like under the armpit?
Yeah.
They get ready to hit the big like uh,
like thick boobos or what they call like the bubonic plague.
That's where that term comes from to get these giant,
oh it's like blood or something like that.
Yeah.
Your,
your,
your lymph nodes are your feet swell up with,
there's some people have read that are immune to it.
Me,
that'd be like me and everything bro.
Hemp powder,
Bro.
You can't fuck with me bro.
Tribal guys that like it goes through so much that like dupont and play good
ball,
all these things they like,
they get it and then nothing happens.
Wow.
That's cool.
Genetics.
But you have to be a travel guy,
right?
Oh,
we have to.
It's probably just get a little bit of Ebola every day,
you know,
and develop an immunity to it.
No,
I think it's a hemorrhagic virus,
right?
Isn't it one of those?
Um,
I think it's one of those ones that makes you bleed.
is it the same one that like liquefies or insights?
Something bad like that.
That's what I heard.
Liquified not good and they just sent some,
they just sent someone to America,
right?
To people to Atlanta.
Yeah.
It's a hemorrhagic fever.
It's a human disease caused by the Ebola virus.
Symptoms typically start two to three weeks after two days to three weeks after
contracting the virus with a fever,
throat,
muscle pains and headaches.
Typically nausea,
vomiting and diarrhea.
Follow along with the decreased functioning of the liver and kidneys.
At this point,
some people begin to have bleeding problems.
The virus may be acquired upon contact with blood or bodily fluids of an
infected animal,
commonly monkeys or fruit bats.
So somebody fucked a bat or a monkey and that's how we got it,
but most likely so he got super crazy and fucked a monkey or a bat.
It's unnaturally transmitted through the air.
Fruit bats are believed to carry and spread the virus without being effected.
Hmm.
Once human infection occurs,
the disease may spread between people as well.
Male survivors may be able to transmit the disease via seaman for nearly two
months.
Wow.
In order to make the diagnosis.
Typically other disease with similar symptoms such as malaria,
cholera,
and other viral hemorrhagic fevers are first excluded.
Wow.
This is deep shit,
man.
No special,
no specific treatment for the disease.
[inaudible] efforts to help persons who are in fact include giving them either
oral rehydration therapy,
slightly sweet and salt,
slightly water to a slightly salty water to drink or intravenous fluids.
The disease has a high mortality rate,
often killing between 50 and 90% of those infected whoa,
whoa.
It was first identified in Sudan and the Democratic Republic of the Congo,
the disease typically occurs in outbreaks in tropical regions of the Subsaharan
Africa.
It's always Africa.
That's where whatever gets us is going to get out of Africa.
You know,
when I,
uh,
I did that Scifi show,
that was the scariest part was the dealing with the infectious diseases by far
what asked people about diseases,
like what we really have to worry about.
The scariest thing they were saying wasn't terrorism.
It was just a disease that morphs just something that becomes like super potent
and kills a ton of people.
Something like they had that Spanish flu that it killed a bunch of people in the
early 19 hundreds.
Yeah.
The 1920s or whatever.
And apparently it started on the military base Q,
the conspiracy theories.
But um,
the,
um,
the thing that was really deadly about it was that it would go after young
healthy men,
that it would,
people with strong immune systems.
It would shut down their immune system.
It would like,
it would kill them quick,
which is like really strange.
You know that it like it was almost designed to take out healthy people.
Yeah.
Cause normally a flu is,
it's like children and old people.
Yeah.
Babies and old people have to worry about it,
but most young people survive.
But that's,
you know,
it's a creepy thought that at any time something could happen and some virus
could morph and turn it into some new thing that we don't know how to deal with.
Yeah.
And someone's sneezing on you at an airport.
Wipe out 5% of human civilization
about this Ebola,
90% of the people die.
Okay.
If that's the high number.
What if everyone got Ebola?
Just think of that.
If one person get Ebola,
what's to say that everyone can't get Ebola while,
because there were specific protocols in place.
Stop that from yes,
most likely.
I'm just being crazy.
Most likely.
Most people are not going to get Ebola,
but if they did,
what we're saying is at least halfway die.
Yeah.
That's,
that's some catastrophic shit.
It's like with the way the world is interconnected,
it's like that could like Tsa doesn't check for Ebola,
like it could get through an airport and the next thing you know,
oh well listen to what that just said,
that it doesn't,
it doesn't necessarily,
the symptoms don't show up that quickly.
Two days to three weeks.
Three weeks is a long time.
You contract a virus and then you,
you have that virus for three weeks and you don't know if you travel a lot.
Travel and licking your hand and touching things everywhere.
High five and people.
Yeah,
you could.
You could spread that shit for sure.
Coughing on a subway,
like there's so many small,
you think about it,
it's on their hand and gives you a hand job.
Right?
That's how you got Ebola.
You're like,
God damn,
really the hottest shit.
Her eyes were really red.
She was probably just high,
but now I feel like temperature,
she was so hot.
She gave me a temperature.
I think she gave me something and I just got to planned parenthood.
They'll figure it.
Planned parenthood.
So what do I have for Ebola?
And you be getting a and jobs from African Jag,
African.
She looks like you have,
we need you to leave immediately.
That's what you have.
Yeah.
So this the woman,
the second patient,
uh,
you know,
there was two patients that,
uh,
that flew into America apparently weak but improving the second American Ebola
patient to arrive in the u us soil was wheeled into an Atlanta hospital Tuesday
by workers in biohazard suits.
You should see the picture,
man.
It's freaky.
The picture is them wheeling her into its dark dude.
Pull that picture up.
Pull this picture up.
There was somebody that they had to a video where they showed him this like news
guy that was hiding in a Bush taking video or photos of this and he wasn't
wearing a suit though.
And it was just like,
oh,
he's like feet away from this person not wearing a suit.
This is how it happens.
This is dumb.
Oh yeah.
That would be like a plot in like the old episode of the incredible hulk.
Right.
That would be out of the guy gets the super disease.
Yeah.
I'm just trying to do my job,
man.
I'm a reporter.
Look at that.
It's so weird looking at them taking that,
that Gurney and pushing it in this space suits.
That's madness.
Ge Ti Hu.
That's so scary.
Ooo,
that's so,
I wonder if it's like 90% though if it,
if it happened in developed nations with like hospitals and shit.
I don't know man.
Cause in tribes like an African show,
when people get it they're like,
oh the diseases back.
Like what did we do?
Like we'll just,
you know,
start a fire and like chant to the gods and like hope that it goes away.
More than 1400 Ebola cases have been confirmed in the worst known outbreak of
the disease and more than 800 people have died.
Most of these cases have been the countries of Guinnea,
Guinea,
Liberia and Sierra Leone,
experimental drug or anything else about the infections ultimately leads to an a
bowl,
a cure.
That would be incredible.
This doctor saying this is dark shit dude.
I didn't know that this was the worst outbreak of Ebola ever.
Did you know that?
No.
Yeah.
Wow.
Those in countries like that too.
They're like,
well,
what?
What next?
I know,
right?
Like what could be worse?
Both aid workers received doses of it experimentally bullet drug derived in part
from tobacco plants and never before tested on humans before they left Liberia.
Brantley got an additional dose at Emory.
Wow,
man,
that's scary shit.
Yeah,
it's pretty crazy.
You know,
whenever there's a movie like that,
a world war Z or any of those movies like it's always the same beginning and
it's the beginning just like this,
like you're reading a story and you're like,
do you think this is really this,
this sounds really bad,
and then one of us would be like,
Nah,
it's nothing.
It's nothing to worry about.
They got on the control.
That's what they do.
These guys are great ad.
That's why it is a CDC guys.
Anyway,
I'm headed to the airport to get on a flight and he's the guy who lands and he's
itchy and it's fucking eyes are bleeding.
What's going on man?
Nothing.
I'll be fine.
I got to go home and hug my wife and children.
You really should take a look at you.
No,
no,
no.
I'm fine.
Thank you.
Now I've got to go to this sporting event.
I've got front row tickets to the Lakers game and I'm not going to miss it.
And he goes there and the Lakers win and you see him high five and everybody
sweating.
Yeah,
he's doing blown the bathroom.
I feel like shit.
She does a couple of bumps and he's high five and everybody sharing needles
just spreading.
You've never done heroin,
but I'll try it today bro.
Yo Lo,
he's doing heroin.
Joe Lowe.
Yeah,
man.
It could happen.
There's a lot of selfish fucking people to oh yeah.
This is a lot of people that,
you know,
I could get HIV.
They don't tell people.
That's a big one,
man.
That's a big one.
John Holmes.
Yeah,
I did it.
Yeah.
This is,
I mean that's um,
that's,
it's a weird thing like you think like if someone caught the Zombie disease and
they knew they had the Zama disease but they knew that it didn't show up for a
couple of weeks,
but they get transmitted to people,
would they still fuck I say they would.
Yeah,
they probably would
be on my side.
I want you to be honest.
I don't want to be the only one with a Zombie disease.
A dude was drinking or seedy hotel room when he ordered up a stripper and he
knew he had the Zombie disease.
I could totally see the
zombies eaves fucking spread.
That's all you'd have to do,
right?
Yeah.
They find a way to rationalize.
Well,
everyone's going to get it anyway.
Exactly.
And she asked me if I had chlamydia or gonorrhea.
I said I didn't lie.
I said,
I didn't have that.
Have,
can you get a broad?
The sooner you accept that,
yeah.
Quicker.
You get some of the suites we push it.
Yeah.
No one ever asked,
you don't have this Zombie disease.
Do,
what are you even talking about?
That's crazy.
So what disease are you fucking see?
Fucking news.
Why would I have come on.
Yeah.
There could be something dark man.
There could be some really crazy AVN.
Swine monkey flew the comes along,
but they just don't see common.
Especially these,
these hammer Rogerick ones.
Ooh,
those are terrified.
Yeah.
We should take these two people that they flew to Atlanta and just like drop
them off in North Korea and you just watch them walk around and you need to
study them.
Find out whether or not the drugs work on them.
Dummy.
It seems like find out like how to fix these people.
Like when they put a lot of money into these things,
like these kinds of projects,
like they have a new drugs,
the trying to test if it works,
the amount of money that they can make from it is giant.
So they're probably working really hard on developing some sort of a cure.
And if they they,
they had enough hope in it.
They injected people with,
it's a good sign.
You know,
it doesn't mean it's going to be effective,
but it means they probably have done a lot of work with it already and they're
pretty sure it does something good.
They're not just taking wild guesses.
Let's just inject him with the first thing that comes to mind.
Tobacco.
Okay,
let's do it.
Fuck it.
Tobacco,
you know there,
there's must be some sort of a reason drugmakers stock falls after big pop.
Hmm.
Why is it knowing ball vaccine,
there is no cure for Ebola.
Do this is the beginning of Gone Gundam horror movie.
Is it people that have it don't have credit cards?
Like why would create a vaccine or a or a drug for people I like,
we can pay you in goats.
It's true.
Here's this an Adobe hut.
Could you imagine if we found out,
and I'm sure someone will suggest it's black helicopters,
but someone will suggest that the reason why this Ebola outbreak has happened
was because someone poisoned a bunch of people with a bola.
It's been shown,
they injected a bola in the drinking water of this tribe so that they could
spread,
the aid workers would bring it back home with them
and then next thing you know this pharmaceutical drug companies making of
dollars.
Yeah,
right.
Someone's going to suggest that,
but it could just be a bola motherfucker.
All right.
Yeah,
could be.
It could just be nature.
People escaped.
They weren't supposed to.
They quarantine people.
People got out.
It spread.
Lots of people die.
They could just be that too and it's most likely just that,
but it's scary.
It's scary as fuck.
It just shows you how easy it is for that shit to actually spread.
Like everything doesn't have to be a conspiracy to be totally terrifying.
Just a disease like this is fucking totally terrifying.
It doesn't have to be manufactured by the government like everybody has this
idea.
When one of these things happens,
like one of the first things that you start reading about,
it's like these government instituted programs with a design viruses that could
not be fought off dark smokey room,
hello world population.
They want to lower the world population.
To 500,000 worldwide.
How do you think they're going to do that?
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
You're like,
I don't know,
but why to pocket billions of dollars.
They will own everything.
500,000 hookers and them
nation.
That's been 500,000 people.
It's not a lot.
That's what the,
uh,
isn't that what the Georgia Guidestones doesn't that say something like that?
So I was like 500 million worldwide,
you know,
the Georgia Guidestones.
What does that,
the Georgia Guidestones are these really tall pieces of stone that were carved
in several different languages with guides for how to run a civilization.
Whoa,
I remember that.
Yeah.
Whoa,
this a here,
I'll pull it up cause it's pretty interesting.
The Georgia Guidestones like the guy who made him,
I'm not sure who that is,
but he,
uh,
he actually had some good guides as far as like how to,
how to,
how to manage a civilization.
Not,
you know,
they're not perfect,
but they're kind of interesting.
Um,
here maintain humanity under 500 million in perpetual balance with nature.
That's one to guide reproduction wisely.
Improving fitness and diversity guide reproduction.
Meaning,
that's like engine engineering,
reproduction.
I mean like a eugenics.
Yeah.
What they're doing is like,
you could say that this is some sort of an evil plot and it may be,
but it also might be that they're just trying to look at it in what you would
consider it cold and calculated manner.
But if you looked at it in Nicole and calculating manner,
I'm not telling you that anybody should do this,
but if you did,
you would want to take the smartest females and breed them with the smartest
males and the ones who had the most good habits,
the months who their most fit.
You would want them to be the ones that would be raising children more often.
You know,
it's just like what you would do if you were raising dogs.
That's an interesting one.
Yeah.
Obama is a Muslim.
Is that on the Georgia Guidestones it is now.
So he spray painted it.
That's so rude.
What else does it say here?
Um,
unite humanity with a living new language.
Whoa.
That's interesting.
Huh?
It doesn't say like emojis a living
new language.
That's interesting.
Like I'm a language for all of humanity that would,
that would really help for sure.
Rule,
passion,
faith,
tradition and all things with tempered reason.
I'm cry.
That's just common sense,
right?
Protect people and nations with fair laws and just courts.
That's Kinda Duh.
Yeah.
Right.
Let all nations rule internally resolving external disputes in a world court.
Okay.
Avoid petty laws and useless officials.
Fuck yes.
Balance personal rights with social duties.
Absolutely.
Prize truth,
beauty.
Love seeking harmony with the infinite and 10 B,
not a cancer on the earth.
Leave Room for nature.
The only thing that's repeated twice in the entire thing.
Hello.
It's not bad idea.
I mean,
listen,
you're gonna need a lot more than that.
It's,
you're on a run a fucking world.
But they're not bad.
There's only a couple of them that are kind of goofy.
There's nothing in there about how to lay fiber optic cables across the fucking
Oh yeah.
Help us out here.
Georgia stone thing.
Where's the Georgia stem thing at?
It's good.
It's Georgia,
I would assume.
So.
Let's find out,
uh,
Elbert County,
Georgia,
uh,
message.
Clearly conveying a set of 10 guidelines as inscribed on the structure in eight
modern languages and he's shorter message is inscribed at the top of the
structure in for ancient languages.
Babylonian,
classical,
Greek,
Sanskrit and Egyptian hieroglyphs.
Wow.
The structure is sometimes referred to as American Stonehenge.
Monument is 19 feet three inches tall,
made from six granite slabs weighing 237,746 pounds.
Why am I reading this?
Nobody cares.
Calves telling lies at the top of the five slabs,
which are astronomically aligned and additional stone tablet,
which is set on the ground short distance to the west of the structure,
provide some notes in the history and the purpose of the Guidestones.
June of 1979 and unknown person or persons under the pseudonym RC Christian
hired Elberton granite finishing company to build a structure.
Wow.
In 2008 the stones were defaced with polyurethane paint death to the new world
order,
like all that shit that we saw.
Wired magazine called the defacement,
the first serious act of vandalism in the Guidestones history.
I wonder if they cleaned that up.
Did they?
Can
they clean that shit up?
Scrape it?
Yeah.
I mean you could still slightly see it,
but,
oh,
that's so annoying.
It's annoying.
Death to the new world order.
Jesus Christ.
Some fucking kids.
Kids are crazy people.
Death to the new world order.
You know?
Imagine if they said,
okay listen man,
we're going to give you a button that kills the new world order.
Okay,
but before you hit that button,
can you at least identify who you're killing?
Yeah,
I mean it's death.
The new world order.
What's the new world order?
Is it the banks or is it the politicians?
Is it everybody?
Yeah,
it's really vague.
Right,
and if you killed them,
what happens to everything?
Because if you go totally deaths in new world order,
what are you going to,
are you going to run the banks?
Who's gonna run the back?
Is there a bank now?
Like how do I get credit?
What it,
how do I use my credit card?
Yeah.
You can't just like hit the button and then be like,
I'm going to go get something to eat now because like your credit card won't
work like it's over.
It's over dude.
You gotta be careful.
You can't death to the new world order maybe enslaved them and force them to
work for us and slave the new world order of forced him to work for us to fix
this problem that they created.
Okay.
I'll be with you.
Get Down with you on the end.
You can't get to the new world or at least can I just tell us how this thing is
running,
you know?
Right before he killed him,
I'd start with like accountability for the new world or like explain yourselves.
Yeah,
we meet.
Why would you ride down on the Georgia Guidestones silly fuck.
The Georgia Guidestones are fascinating.
I think it's interesting to me.
I don't know who the dude is or unknown dudes or dudettes.
Yeah.
Especially since they commissioned like a place to do it.
I like to don't tell anyone we were here.
Well you can rock it that way.
In 1979 though,
you know,
1979 like no DNA.
There was no credit cards.
There was no nothing.
A paper receipt with a carbon coffee.
Yeah.
Gave you that was,
that was the only record.
Yeah.
People used to buy groceries with checks all the time.
You would like see women at the cash register and you know they would be
reading.
Okay.
Was that they would pay with a check.
Like that was super common.
Now it's rare when I see someone paying with a check I get kind of excited.
Really?
Yeah.
Like it's like a legacy thing.
Like whoa.
Yeah,
I can see that much longer.
It's kind of cool to,
it's always old people.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Or you know there's some housewives,
you know,
sometimes people,
they like to balance their checkbook like that.
That's how they make sure that they keep an accurate assessment of what's in
there.
But now you can bounce a check book like looking at you,
you look it up online,
not balanced it,
but at least be aware you could do it pretty easily.
Find out what your balances.
The craziest thing is you can send a check on,
you can take a picture of a check and send it over the Internet at deposit it
and using the phone.
Well how about all these businesses now that have these phone apps that you,
you put a thing on your phone,
you just swipe a credit card and you can pay for a credit card with your phone.
Yeah,
they,
a lot of businesses have those things now I square it was like the big one,
right?
Yeah.
That that changes like merge on the,
you can go,
oh I know except credit cards and my iPhone.
Do you have one of those?
Cause you have an LLC right?
For desk squad.
So you have one of those you put on your phone?
Yeah,
I have one for like shows and Shit when you sell tee shirt.
I've never had really done that dude.
Why are you not doing that?
That sounds perfect.
Yeah,
that sounds cool as fuck.
You know,
so independent I cam home business.
Yeah.
This I would wait,
are you saying there's a problem?
Do you not do it because there's like some issue now.
I just did it just uh,
you know,
if you're selling a $10 poster,
you usually people who have $10,
you know,
so it's,
it's not necessary but I,
if
I
brought we fucking next subject,
next Trump.
But no,
it works good.
I mean my weed dealer sells it easy bro.
Him under the bus to speed week.
You throw him under the bus.
No,
it's cool.
I'd like every,
you know,
like a lot of small businesses like smaller,
like mom and pop stores use that now instead of having the big credit card
machine that they just have like an iPad sitting there that you just sign.
Yeah,
it makes sense.
I went to a coffee place recently that a,
you swipe your credit card and then you write on the screen.
Right.
You know,
you're right.
You're saying the screen.
What's really crazy is that like there's like these little tablets and it's all
this really complicated screen,
high definition touch screen,
super accurate,
but you're still like doing this thing with your fucking,
you're putting your mark.
That's how you prove it's you.
That's so goofy,
goofy.
It's just weird that that's still the way we do it and it doesn't even matter
anymore.
Like you don't,
there's no need to go through that.
I did once.
I was cause I was looking at one of these signs and things.
I'm like this no way it matters.
And I wrote in the signature box matter stolen card and I hit submit and I
totally,
yeah,
it's just they want to get a record of you making a mark on that paper.
You're making a mark on that screen.
What do you think will happen?
Because there's,
they're going to stop teaching cursive in school and they're already starting to
thank God.
What's going to happen with signatures?
That's good question.
That's a very good question.
Well,
what are we going to,
how are we going to sign things?
Like if you never learn cursive,
what are we going to all have like codes.
Do you think that the idea of signing things is ridiculous and isn't it kind of
ridiculous?
The idea of signing things like you shed
the idea that you're bound to an agreement,
these wavy lines that you put on paper.
There's certain things that I think like business dealings,
like say if you and I decided to build a house together,
like nick and Joe go into construction business and we decided to build and we
have a business and the businesses 50 50 and you,
we pay for the same amount for this and that and we get the same amount of
profit and you got that all worked out.
That kind of makes sense to do that.
But there's a lot of things that you signed for like cable agreements,
you know,
or cell phone contracts or there's literally entanglements,
business entanglements.
There's a contract to get a cell phone.
Have I have to have a contract like what is this?
When I'm,
what am I agreeing to?
I'm agreeing to what is,
this is ridiculous.
There's a whole documentary,
I watched a Netflix about terms and conditions and all the things that you sign
away the second you.
Yeah.
Who fucking reads that shit?
Nobody.
And that's why they get away with putting all kinds of insane shit.
And what's the documentary called?
It's called like we're fucked or
really terrible.
I think it's called like terms and conditions,
terms and sending.
It's on,
it's on Netflix and it's,
it's pretty interesting that they go through all the different companies and
like,
uh,
which ones like,
well we'll sell your personal information because you've agreed that the second
you hit click yes on iTunes or like you agreed to apples the second you turn on
your iPhone or something like that,
they can store your information,
they can sell it if the government needs it.
They used to be like,
we will not give out your information.
And then they've changed the clause to like,
you know,
unless like it,
it'll be words like,
unless certain things come up the fuck does that mean he just be anything less
certain things.
They're so vague about it unless like shit goes down,
you're like,
you can't say that.
It's just,
what is that?
That South Park Episode,
Human Sin and pad where it's all about Apple's terminus and conditions ends up
having like you signed this guy's ass
south park's the best.
That's so great.
Yeah,
and nobody reads it.
I would like,
I would love to know what the actual numbers of people who read the terms and
conditions before they click on it.
It's going to be half a percent if that.
Right.
That means so much.
That means half a percent is one person out of 200 right?
Isn't that what it means?
I think,
well,
yeah,
right?
Yeah.
1% would be one out of 100 so half a percent is 1% of 200 does that make sense?
So I don't,
I don't believe that.
Does he think it's even less?
Yeah.
I think it's probably
not even,
not 1% but like one 10th of 1% I bet it's one out of a thousand that's what I
bet.
Yeah,
that makes more sense.
One out of a thousand actually reads the whole thing and he goes,
well,
I want to click on this.
Let me see.
Yeah,
it sounds reading glasses as fucking God damn liberal president we have here and
trying to calm me and asmark countries.
Yeah.
That guy will read it
and they tell that
they tell you in
the documentary if you spent all the time reading every time like a new terms
and conditions comes up for all the different things that make you sign when it
[inaudible] it would take like years of your life you have to take like days off
of work to be like dude I just sign up for Netflix,
Spotify and I got a new iPhone.
So like I can't come into work today because I have to read like 860 pages of
legal jargon.
Yeah.
It should be at a certain point in time.
It should be that your method of delivery is so woefully ineffective that it's
illegal.
Like a terms and conditions on that scale.
If I could prove that my theory was correct and then it's like one half of 1% or
one 10th of 1% rather that that actually read that thing,
they'll should be illegal.
Yeah.
Cause you're making people sign things and they're just not reading,
you know,
they're not reading it.
Yeah.
You're like misleading.
You're intentionally making it more difficult.
They make everything so rock solid in their favor and even things that like just
shouldn't be that way.
There's certain agreements like when you find out that anytime you cancel,
anytime you,
you know,
you want to change this,
you're subject to fees,
you're subject to that and you'll let you find out things about your
information,
your history,
they're selling your phone number or your email.
And there's so many things that happen to people when you sign those little
things away.
But we do it recklessly.
Yeah.
I don't ever think about it.
Have you ever had a,
an app that you click the yes.
On then it started making tweaks for you?
Yeah,
there's there,
especially on Android,
there's a lot of sketchy things that like a year installing so they can also
track you like any,
they,
whoever made this app and track you.
It's weird.
Yeah.
I had a guy,
um,
he made some app,
uh,
that tweeted for me something about like a how do a prize for an Ipad,
you know,
and a,
and someone said,
dude,
you hawk an iPad.
And I was like,
what are you talking about?
And then I went to my thing,
I was like,
what the fuck is this?
And then I found out where it was from this guy,
I guess I had like retweeted something from a website.
Like sometimes when you retweet something,
like if you go to a website and you click on it a story or something that you
think is interesting and you,
there's like a tweet button but if you tweet it like sometimes you were agreeing
to allow them to have access to your Twitter account or at least used to be that
way.
Well,
a lot of those websites,
that's how you,
they steal your credit or your a password asa because you go in and order to
complete like tweet this story and this is like you need to log in and what it's
doing,
it's actually stealing your password and logging you in at the same time.
So it looks like everything's going right.
And then that's how a lot of people will get fished for there.
Yeah,
I could only imagine,
but uh,
there's dude's somehow or another,
it had like an APP installed on my Twitter.
It was like,
you know those,
those things that are attached to your Twitter,
you know,
there's like Evernote and you can tweet with Evernote and there's a bunch of
different ones.
This guy had like this installed on my computer.
I was like,
what the fuck?
So I go to his website,
his website is like,
um,
you know it his Twitter page or like a hundred thousand fucking friends or
whatever it is.
Followers.
Like how's he doing that?
Like just scams all around.
You automatically add them?
Probably,
yeah,
I do a search to find out what like what kind of traffic is websites getting
ridiculous traffic cause this is all this weasel work going on,
you know,
sneaky people that forced you into clicking on things are tricky and the
clicking on things,
next thing you know,
they're tweeting about iPad giveaways from your account.
You're like,
what?
And then you find out that that's legal.
Yeah.
You,
you,
you actually clicked on a thing that says you're allowed to do that.
Yeah.
It's bizarre.
Like if after watching that documentary made me want to like just not sign up
for a lot of websites when I'm like,
do I really want that?
Do I need that?
Because I'm not going to read the terms and conditions.
Yeah.
Hello Brian Denning sentenced to 15 months in prison.
Who is that?
Ooh,
remember Brian?
Yeah,
Brian Dunning was the guy.
I had him on my podcast and we had a very contentious discussion I sad to hear.
And He um,
he had a,
um,
an issue with,
believe it was Amazon,
right?
Bang.
Yeah.
And he had created some sort of an APP.
And if you use the APP it,
it puts a cookie on your,
uh,
on your,
on your computer.
Like if you use it,
it puts a cookie on your computer.
And then anytime you go to Ebay and make a purchase or do business,
he would get like a kickback.
And the way he described the way described it is very different.
So I don't know who's right or who's wrong,
but what they're accusing him of is you plant something on,
you're like a plant,
a cookie.
And then even if you don't go to Ebay through his website,
it appears that you did.
So they have like these ebay affiliates where say like if nick use of.com if I
went through that and then went to Ebay and purchase something,
you would get like a little tiny piece of the action.
And over time that counts.
That counts for a lot.
And because these apps were popular account for a lot,
and he made a lot of money,
5 million.
Whoa.
Yeah.
He made $5 million off the APP and then they,
uh,
they shut it down and arrested him.
And when we had them on the podcast,
I do not think he's a bad guy,
but there's something wrong with the way he thinks.
And what would I say that I say that with all,
all respect and dignity,
um,
communicating about a fellow human being,
like I don't hate that guy.
He's silly.
And he said a bunch of crazy shit about me.
Um,
but I think he's,
I think there's something wrong with the way he thinks I'm thinking.
And I even communicated with him about that in private.
We had like a little email conversation and he actually asked me about
psychedelic drugs and he's curious about the mind expanding aspects.
And we had a,
we had a pretty intense conversation about it.
Um,
because I think,
and I,
and I told him that,
I said with due respect,
I think there's something wrong with the way you think.
Like,
I don't know what it is,
but I think it's like a mental illness.
His,
his versions of reality and reality itself are so twisted.
Like there was a video that we watched of tower seven from September 11th
falling and he was trying to convince us that it doesn't collapse into its base.
He was trying to convince us that only three quarters of the tower,
the three quarters of the tower is still standing.
It was only the top quarter or whatever it was.
He had some weird numbers in his head and I'm like,
what are you talking about that that thing gives out and falls into a pile.
Like the reason why it's so high is because that's how much shit there is.
The whole thing's gone.
Like the building disintegrate.
It's not a cartoon.
I'll just vanishes.
Yeah,
it's all on top.
exactly.
It's on for rent signs,
stack of Shit.
The reason why the stack is so high is because there was a lot of shit above it.
It felt like this is retarded like this,
but he wouldn't let it go and what I was looking at him when he wouldn't let it
go.
It's like,
oh,
there's something wrong in there.
Like there's a,
there's a missing thing.
And then when he started talking about his life,
it made way more sense because he was raised a very,
very conservative Mormon,
like his whole life.
He was very religious and he's,
he's developed his mind developed under this fundamentalist thinking that is
super damaging to people.
And that sounds like an ignorant bigot and an anti religious thing for me to
say.
But just listen to this for a second.
I have friends that grew up Mormon and they to this day tell me that they're
really gullible.
They worry about it.
They don't,
they don't know whether or not someone is trying to pull a fast one on them.
They don't know whether or not like a yoga guru or a cult member could rope them
in and suck them into things by telling them that they found a seat.
Like they have this weird need to believe irrational things.
And this is when this woman who tells me herself,
it disturbs her.
She's like,
I don't know what it is,
but I have this weird like I'm,
I'm susceptible to trickery.
And I was like,
whoa.
I thought it was a weird admission and she was just talking.
She was like,
as I've gotten older and she's not dumb,
she's like,
as I've gotten older and I've talked to my other friends,
I'm like,
well what is it about me and she's like,
because all my life I thought that God had my back all my life.
I thought that God has everything covered in.
Everything's going to be fine until over and over again.
Fucked up.
Things would happen to her and she was forced to go wait,
what's going on here?
And then she would see the ridiculous hypocrisy of the church.
She looked into the religion deeper than got to be like your forties and is
looking at her life going,
fuck yeah,
like what is this and why am I,
why am I,
that guy is like that.
He grew up super religious when you grew up super religious like that,
especially if you don't have open minded parents,
like there's a way I think that you could grow up with a sense of spirituality
and still be very open minded and maybe scientifically inclined.
But the reason why this guy is like such a,
these like going after things like debunking things showing,
Huh,
this is all nonsense.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I give you ever seen his video on fracking?
Yeah.
That's the perfect example of there's like a no nonsense voice that people use
and it's like there's a tone.
This is like a very condescending way of communicating their ideas.
It's the no nonsense guy.
And there's a lot of things that are misunderstood about hydraulic fracturing,
otherwise known as fracking.
You ever seen him pull that video up?
Cause this was back in the day when I first saw it.
What did you believe that fracking was?
Real?
What do you mean?
I mean,
I'm tracking,
I'm sorry.
Nevermind.
I believe they wouldn't though.
Fracking is totally real.
They make a lot of money off of fracking.
Son,
what did you,
uh,
what were you talking about?
This little things in the cameras?
I was thinking of that things in the Cam.
Remember like the lines,
oh you talking about like the,
the rods.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
No that's totally different.
That guy's mad at me.
That rod guy,
the right guy.
They've clowned him on that.
A monster quest show.
Do you know,
uh,
with the rods are there the,
there's a visual artifact that comes when bugs fly across the screen,
but bugs move really fast.
And if you don't have a super high speed camera,
I can't capture the bug.
So it elongates the shape of the bug because it's this little tiny thing moving
quickly and it looks like a translucent tube that's moving through the air and
it's just a video artifact of video cameras trying to capture high speed bugs.
And this guy made all these documentaries about this,
these things flying in the air man.
And you could only see him on camera.
They moved too fast with the human eye,
which doesn't make any sense.
Cause if I can see them on the camera,
like the video,
that's not too fast for the human eye.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm seeing the video of it.
It's like this is actually slower than the human eye can perceive you.
The human eye sees shit.
You know?
Like Hey,
what does that fucking him?
Some shit flying flat.
You would see it.
This is so stupid.
Like if you could see to the video,
you would see it in real life.
It's so dumb.
And he tried to run with a conspiracy that he made documentary.
Me and Eddie Bravo got stoned.
It's fucking watched it and were like,
dude,
there's,
what do you think these rods are?
We're so high were so ridiculous.
We're go,
we're using the arm man.
It's crazy that you can't see them.
I'm like,
that doesn't even make any sense,
man.
It doesn't even make any sense.
So you think they're everywhere.
They're everywhere.
They're just moving so fast.
We can't see them.
They're like,
that's so crazy.
Maybe we should put up a new us.
We should put up a net and try to catch him.
Yo,
there's so fast.
They see the net,
they're gone.
You're right,
you're right.
You're right.
Otherwise,
like they would slam into planes and shit.
They get killing them off of planes.
Here it is.
Listen to Brian talk about hydraulic fracturing.
Then sand is mixed with the water and gets distributed throughout the cracks to
prop them open.
The water is then pumped back out and now the gas can freely float to the
borehole.
The controversy comes mainly from the fact that about one half of one of the
fluid
consists of lubricants and surfactants.
We needed to get the controversy comes to the fact that people can't drink their
water anymore.
Man.
This hydraulic fracturing like this,
that's one of those things that you bring up in a conversation on podcasts and
people go fucking bananas.
It's a global warming type issue.
Really?
Yeah.
You know,
global warming.
If you believe in global warming or if you don't believe in global warming,
you're gonna piss somebody off and then getting get heated tweets about it.
People get fucking furious because it's an,
it's an ideology argument and people that abortion support,
yes.
People that support hydraulic fracturing support business.
No.
You don't understand nick use if you fucking Hippie,
you understand business.
Okay.
The way business gets done is it's cheaper to get that oil out than it is to
rely on foreign oil and endanger Americans.
Like it's that sort of attitude.
It's like,
and then there's the people that are like environmentally conscious.
Go,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
What's happening?
Like how much water is getting polluted?
Like how many wells are there?
There's millions who,
hold on,
wait a minute,
you guys have a million fracking wells?
There's a million and it's causing earthquakes too.
Well,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
You can't,
well,
what we need now,
it's not hippies.
What we need now now oil,
patriotism,
oil.
I'm not pro or con fracking,
these gentlemen.
I'm not opposed to putting a fence around a certain area of like South Dakota
where nobody goes and fracking the shit out of that bitch and not having to go
to war for fall foreign oil.
I'm not totally opposed to that.
My problem is I don't think it's controlled.
I don't,
and when you talk about like,
all right,
let's guess how many fracking wells are there?
Let's take it.
Take a wild guess.
They've been fracking in Ohio lately and now we have all these earthquakes.
Yeah.
Proven.
That's so scary.
Okay.
How many fracking wells in the u s a thousand.
That's so cute.
That's a really low number.
Oh,
that's so close.
Low to look.
You're handsome bastard,
but that,
no,
I'm saying it's so low.
It's ridiculous.
I bet it's more than a billion,
I would say.
Yeah,
I think so.
I would say yeah,
5,000 to 10,000 that's it.
Okay.
You guys say in the thousands would you say I said I said around a thousand you
said five thousand ten thousand I said a million.
I bet you guys were right.
Okay.
2013 to two two,
two,
two.
What's the numbers?
So numbers over 1.1 million active oil and gas wells in the u s whoa.
Wow.
All right.
How many of them are fractured?
Many people ask us how many wells have been hydraulically fracture?
The United States?
It's an excellent question,
but not one that's easily answered.
Most states don't release the data on well stimulation activities.
Also,
since the data are released by state regulatory agencies,
it is necessary to obtain data from each state that has oil and gas data to even
begin the conversation.
We finally had a chance to complete the task and have able to be,
uh,
able to aggregate the following totals.
Wow.
This is pretty nuts,
man.
There's a lot of fucking Wellsboro.
There's over a million.
Whoa.
That's crazy.
Ooh,
that's scary,
man.
How is that a better idea than investing in like solar paneling and like
alternate sources?
I Dunno.
There's a bunch of different kinds of wells though.
So let me just clarify that.
There's,
um,
directional.
There's a bunch of different types,
directional,
horizontal,
either direction or horizontal.
Vertical,
hydraulically fractured,
not fractured,
unknown or shale formation.
So all of these,
all of these,
it's a million,
but it says hydraulically fractured.
It says one 30.
But does that mean is only 130 fracking wells as east state releases data
differently?
It wasn't always possible to get consistent data on fracking wells.
These wells are known to be hydraulically flat fractured,
but the slant of the well is unknown.
Oh,
I see.
Okay.
They have a bunch of different ways that they get the wall,
the water out,
or get the oil out.
This is fascinating shit,
man.
They go down,
then they take turns.
They're like,
they'll go down and then take left turns or they'll go like horizontally or the
good and angle into the earth,
depending on where the,
where the rock is and where the oil is.
They're trying to suck out.
Wow.
That's how crazy fucking thing man.
Hydraulically fractured.
Okay.
Here it is.
[inaudible] wells that have been hydraulically fractured might appear in any of
the eight categories with the obvious exception of not fractured.
So that's the only one that doesn't have a hydraulically fractured wells
included in it.
So a categories that are very likely to be fractured include horizontal,
hydraulically fractured and unknown shale formation.
The total of which is 32,000 wells.
That's most likely to be fractured.
So they don't know,
but at least 32,000 however,
the number doesn't include any wells from Texas or Colorado where we know
thousands of wells have been drilled into major shell formation,
shale formations.
But the data for which had to be placed into categories that were more vague.
So there's different states have different like regulatory bodies,
I guess the states that are better to to fucking rape the earth and
they probably are better off hiding the information to,
so it seems like,
um,
what they're saying is like 32,000 plus hydraulically fractured ones that they
could locate that they'd know are most likely hydraulically fractured.
But then there's a bunch of the other ones that could,
and the ones that aren't fractured,
there's only 7,477 of them out of the 1,136,000.
What's crazy is that they create earthquakes.
Yeah,
it's fucked.
And then it's still like,
Nah,
it's worth it.
It's worth it.
It's worth it if you keep your family warm.
Yeah.
It's for American America.
Save America.
Save America's going to be a puddle of Goo Stinky puddle of Goo and dead elk
choking bison with their fucking lego though.
When hair gagging blood out,
they have a new Ebola that comes only from oil.
Right?
Yeah.
I don't know man.
I just wish there's a better way to power shit.
I wonder if there would,
like if there was no oil,
let's say the oil didn't exist,
how far do you think civilization would have gone?
Because there's no doubt that the combustion engine and making machines and the
trucks and engines and that's the reason why we became what we are today.
There's this fucking chaotic mass super organism that we are right.
So if there was no oil,
if that wasn't an an element on earth and the only kid to have like plant based
oils like
sunflower oil or some shit.
Yeah,
hemp oil,
you know,
which they used for lamps and stuff.
They use like different kinds of oils for lamps but no oil in the ground.
How far would things have gotten?
I Dunno cause how long would it have taken?
This is the part of the conversation with Brian checks out.
Um,
who knows like cause how long would it have been before you'd found an alternate
way?
Like the electric car,
like how long did that take?
Forever.
But you need it.
You need combustion engines to make all those things.
See what making an electric car,
there's,
you need an engine to take the parts to get the parts to the car manufacturer to
deliver the stuff.
Like those are all being delivered with trucks,
right?
Like this idea that like you get electric car and your Karma free.
This is nonsense.
What does that,
that technology would,
it had been created for the manufacturing.
Everything would had to been run electrically.
Exactly.
But how long would it have taken?
Forever to discover.
Yeah,
forever.
Without the,
the motor to take the parts to put it together.
Like you had to pick up the tire somewhere and driving.
Those aren't electric trucks,
you know,
it would have been like wagons.
That was so many years.
Oxen would have had oxen pulling your fucking tires.
And then how are they going to figure out a way to power up these machines?
What's the going to fire up the electricity?
They're gonna use that dam and the dam fires up the electricity for these
machines and these machines build this engine and,
and is there enough electricity to charge batteries and where are you guys
getting the batteries?
Where are you getting the minerals that go into batteries?
You've got to go to Afghanistan,
man.
Yeah,
you got a drill for them.
How are you going to get to Afghanistan?
The oxen can't swim.
You gotta take a fucking raft,
fill it up with minerals from Afghanistan.
If floaty back to America,
build your stupid electric.
The battery would have been invented in like 1973 it would have taken that long.
This is what Obama meant when he was like,
when you started a smart built small business,
you didn't build that.
That's what he meant.
The infrastructure.
You cannot have an electric car without the infrastructure.
Right.
They created batteries back in the Egyptian days though.
Yeah.
So they might,
might have been,
I think they could have probably done something.
It would have been,
well those batteries were dog shit.
By the way.
Everybody's like,
iPhone batteries are amazing.
They weren't even iPhone one.
They weren't even close.
They were stupid.
They wouldn't even Duracell.
Those bitches could even power a light.
Like you couldn't like I have like the,
the light,
the power is your cell phone.
You're like,
I went out to close my chicken coop last night and uh,
when I use my phone as a flashlight,
the new iPhone has a,
an uh,
like builtin flashlight thing.
Yeah.
You slide this thing up and he hit that and boom,
you've got a flashlight.
It takes two seconds.
It's built in.
It's such a slick thing.
You know,
God's side.
That wouldn't work.
That it's stupid.
Egyptian battery,
big goof ass thing.
Got a carrier on this pot.
Copper core.
Yes.
He made a big one.
Like the size of a,
you know,
like a pyramid.
You stepped pyramid was all battery the whole time.
Do you imagine that?
That's what it was soothing to our battery.
We'll be up for her whole pyramids.
A post that was like one of the crazy conspiracy theory hypothesis.
The pyramid was a giant,
some sort of a power plant.
Really?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah of course.
Believe it.
If you can think it up,
somebody has like probably written blog entries about it doesn't matter how
cookie the idea is.
If you could think up a Kooky idea,
somebody has written some shit about it.
I was thinking of bugs the other day because there was a praying mantis that was
on my porch that just hung out the whole whole day and he has these huge
antennas and I was like,
isn't it weird that we don't really focus like these bugs have like antennas on
them like in the future,
like we're going to find out that these are like aliens that are communicating
with each other through some,
well they might as well be aliens.
We just don't give a shit about him cause they're a little,
yeah,
we can just kick them out of the way.
Little drones,
you know their drones for aliens.
There's like these little what they are.
It's a weird little life form that shares the world with us that has no morals,
no ethics.
So ruthless coldhearted emotionless killers.
And they have a hard skeleton.
They don't need each other's touch.
Yeah.
They have this very bizarre military organization as far as they have a queen,
you know,
they have,
they have a,
the worker bees and they're,
they're building shelter and protecting the hive.
And they're weird man.
We just don't think of him as being so weird cause they're little.
And we could just wait for him like that.
But if a bear this big,
oh I know.
Yeah.
But a lot of them it's like,
whoa.
Like if they all of a sudden became big,
we're like fuck.
And then we're like,
oh cool.
They only live for four days.
Thank God.
Neutralized soon.
Yeah.
But there's so many of them.
Before we start killing them off with cell phones,
cell and pesticides.
Apparently the third one that's whacked them out.
I remember when you were a kid,
bees were everywhere.
How often do you see being,
have you seen bees every day at my house?
You,
but do you see bees like you saw on beans when you were a kid?
Well,
I haven't tended be like bees nests everywhere.
You do?
Yeah.
Really?
Wow.
Sucks.
Maybe you got a sweet spot for bees and wasps.
I see.
Populations are pretty down though aren't thing.
Wasn't that like a,
it's a major concern.
Let's say dropping bee populations.
Let's play another game.
I say bee populations are down by 40%.
40.
Wow.
I would say 25,
20% to 25%.
What'd He say,
Ryan?
Uh,
I say it's up.
I say,
I think it's a big conspiracy.
I think these are more ever because it all around Brian's house.
We have a bee problem lead to stop these bees.
Okay.
30%.
Um,
it's even crazier.
30% in the U s beekeepers experience losses of 40 or 50% or more.
Wow.
Well,
yeah,
just says commercial B operations prepared to transport their hives to the
country's largest pollinator event.
The fertile is fertilizing of California's almond trees.
Oh,
that's interesting.
So they,
um,
I guess they hire people to go do that.
They bring bees and the bees a populate or,
uh,
bees pollinate these plants.
That's pretty cool.
Wow.
Spread out across 800,000 acres.
California's almond orchards typically require 1.6 million domesticated bee
colonies to pollinate the flowering trees and produce what has become the
state's largest overseas agricultural export.
I did not know that almonds are largest overseas export.
And why is that?
Because weeds illegal bitch,
if we was legal t you don't think that people in like Portugal would be dying to
get ahold of some Goddamn California weed.
Um,
but given widespread be losses to so called colony collapse disorder.
This winter,
California's almond growers were able to pollinate their crop only through an
intense nationwide push to cobble together the necessary number of healthy bee
colonies.
Wow.
Nationwide push.
That's crazy.
That's how they grow almonds at the top saying it's amazing.
So cool.
I love when I find out something like this where I had no idea that they,
I didn't know that I thought bees,
they may,
they just made honey and you know,
they're pollinated shit,
but I didn't know that they needed him to grow almonds.
Yeah,
they're domesticated.
That's crazy,
man.
I thought they only did one thing.
They make two delicious items.
Almonds.
Yeah.
If it wasn't around,
that's amazing.
But that these colonies were down and that in order to pollinate all of their
plants,
they need to,
they needed to bring in other bees.
There's not like another possibility.
They're like,
no,
no.
We need bees.
But isn't there another method?
Let's,
let's put our heads together and no,
no,
no.
Let's go.
Not going to grow.
You need bees are,
it's not going to grow.
That really puts into light how important bees are.
Something like that that really makes you realize like,
oh,
like if it's not for bs,
there's,
there's not a lot of shit.
Like you need those little cunty bugs.
Yeah.
That's bizarre,
man.
And there's this image on,
um,
the,
uh,
this,
Yale site where I'm reading the story and there's this dude who's dressed up in
this beekeeper's outfit and he's like handling these bees and moving them around
in these,
uh,
California farms,
these a onion crops.
And you're looking at and be like,
how was that much different than the Ebola guy would have it?
I mean,
he's,
he's got a fucking crazy suit as well,
and that is fully suited up for an invasion of attacking monsters.
You know,
what does that Brian's 20 Hinchcliffe dressed up as a B.
He is
the greatest movie of all time.
What's,
what do wasps do?
Anything positive you fuck up?
Bees?
WASPS would say the ones that can keep stinging you as where it'd be like,
it's like,
wow.
It's like a kamikaze mission.
It's like one and done
wasps.
Yeah.
Have you ever seen that video?
The Japanese Hornets killing the beehive?
No.
Ooh,
it's the weirdest video ever,
man.
Because it's this.
If we put it on,
it'll probably get us kicked off of Youtube.
Right?
Is that how it works?
That's one really.
It's one of those ones,
these nature documentaries,
man,
they'd go after you and have you pulled from youtube what?
Yeah.
Nature documentaries.
People own them.
You know,
that probably cost a grip of money to film high speed video footage of some
Japanese Hornets.
Fucking up some honey bees.
But just do me a favor.
Go just Google Japanese Hornets.
Fuck up honeybees and check it out because it's amazing.
They're monsters.
They're the cut their heads off.
They just cut the honeybees heads off and like,
I think it was like 30 bees killed 30,000 bees or 30 hornets killed 30,000 bees,
something nutty like that.
It's like darn near 11 war,
but it's not a war.
It's like you with a hatchet and a room full of babies.
It's like there's no,
no one's fighting back.
I mean,
they can't do anything.
They just chopped their heads off
or something along those lines.
Right?
Like the only way they can kill them is they have to overheat them.
So they do is they all swarm on top on the hold the,
the Hornet down and they,
they keep buzzing.
They buzz on them and raise his internal temperature until he dies.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
That's the only way they can kill him.
They can't kill him.
I stadium doesn't work.
I can't get through their fucking armor.
So they just turn the heat up until they die.
They smother him,
they fucking torture them.
It's the only way to do it.
What else would you do?
Just trying to eat your babies.
Chop their heads off.
Fuck.
It's
crazy that he's like,
invasions are happening with living a such a small level.
You think bees are dumb be just flying around making honey and meanwhile they're
like,
here's the plan.
All right,
we're going in and we're going to heat the fucking place up until everyone dies.
Well the the,
no,
the,
the bees do that to the hornets,
but
the do,
what they do is say one horn,
it will be a scout Hornet and the scout Horner will show up and when the scout
horn it shows up.
That's when the bee swarm it,
the bee swarm it and hold it down and try to kill it because if they don't kill
it,
if it gets back to the horn,
snazzy goes,
Yo,
I found Sam B.
That's when shit gets crazy.
That's when they fly back and fuck everybody up.
That's insane.
Yeah.
That world,
the Hornet B,
you know,
I think of them as sort of the same sort of category.
These flying bugs.
It's staying like that world is unbelievably ruthless.
Yeah.
The fact that first of all,
the fact that there's their stingers kill them too,
right?
Like when they extinct a person or something,
it pulls out of their body.
Like it's this giant sword that pulls out their body and they die.
That happens when they have sex that happens when they sting.
Yeah.
They only live to be like a week old.
Like if they're lucky and if they sting you,
they die.
And then on top of that,
like the female can stink all the time.
Like the Queen,
she doesn't have to worry about her Barb coming out.
She can just staying all day long.
It was,
but all she does is seek out other females.
So she walks around the hive and smells each individual little honeycomb in
those little combs where the bees grow up in whatever that's on a honeycomb.
What is it?
Uh,
one of those things,
I'm not a comb.
Whatever it is,
whatever those little pods larva are growing.
If she finds that it's a female,
she uses her,
her fucking Stinger and stabs the baby.
What?
Yup.
That's what it's for.
No other women,
no other women.
Other women.
There can be only one.
She's Highlander.
Damn.
Yeah.
She walks around and stabs all the females because it fucks all the dudes to
death.
Yup.
Fucks him to death.
She's as as gangster as fuck.
That's a gangster pitch.
Wow.
That might be the most gangster bitch of the animal kingdom.
Right?
I mean powerful sword on her pussy because how many other like praying mantis or
black widows I guess.
Right.
Okay.
Here's the mail.
Who would win in a fight?
A praying mantis or a wasp praying mantis.
Okay.
Um,
I'm going to go with the wasp wasp versus praying man.
I'd say praying man.
A female praying man has decapitates her like fucks the dude and then yeah,
those guys are bitches.
I don't know the man is versus wasp.
Okay.
There's probably reach a rent.
Like if the wasp was like,
I'm going to stab you in the back.
That praying man,
that's probably couldn't get it.
Yeah,
but maybe the,
they have like hard skeletons that they can't be pierced by bees.
I'm going to go praying mantis.
Interesting.
Is that your bird?
Yeah,
I'm watching this pregnant.
Okay.
The amazing thing is if only the wasp knew how vulnerable the plane praying
Mantis is,
could in numbers easily sting at to death,
but it doesn't.
The answer lies in the camouflage strategy of the Mantis.
And now the wasp usually visualizes the mantis among the foliage.
The mantis is not seen as a threat to the wasp.
Large female praying mantis almost ready to produce her egg case needs one last
meal.
It's a European wasp.
It says the bullies of the insect world insect mimicry.
They oh,
okay.
So guests,
uh,
that's the answer.
They're fucking praying names.
That giant Hornet versus a praying man.
It's the whoa dude.
This praying Mantis fucked this wasp up quick.
The Wasp is walking around.
It's too,
it's pretty dope.
I wish we could show it and not get pulled off of youtube.
Whatever happens to those when we get pulled over those.
Jamey,
do we get back on?
Yes and no?
Yes and no.
This is worth watching,
dude.
Look at this one.
Yeah,
that's the one I'm watching.
Praying masters.
I think we could make,
well I'm praying mantises are gangster.
They fuck wasps.
The wasp don't have a chance.
He just holds them and starts eating them.
That's,
it's really crazy.
They're so strong.
They just eat the wasps back.
Just hang on and them.
Yeah.
That's a fucking vicious,
vicious animal.
The world of those,
those creatures is just so evil and alien.
We just don't think about it cause they're so small.
Yeah.
Their level.
It's like ruthless people.
Like not people,
but the other animals are like,
they run scared.
But for us it's like a pair of vans can just take them both out at once.
Yeah.
They're these other bees or swimming or a flying round.
This praying man.
It's not sure how to save their friend,
but they don't know what to do while this wasp is getting eaten alive,
eating the back of his head.
It's horrific,
man.
He's just holding onto it and just eating it.
We just,
we're,
we're looking at it in this tiny scale so it doesn't seem that horrific.
But if a praying mantis is a size of a Giraffe,
you know,
and we saw it chase after a hippo and jacket and it was fucking up this hippo in
front of all the other hippos and there wasn't a God damn thing they could do
about it.
They just had to sit there and just deal with the fact had this huge mechanized
looking beach
taking chunks out of the hippos head
and they're like,
oh fuck.
Do we go over there and save him?
What do we do?
That's why I like size is in the animal kingdom is so relevant because when you
get really low,
wow,
there's a pre masters Jack that be,
they don't
play games,
man.
They don't play games.
They're so strong.
They just hold onto the beach and start eating them.
Is that his death rattle?
Yeah.
He's just trying to fly away.
He's trying to fly away.
Look how much stronger those things are.
That's like he plants his leg,
John Jones versus Bobby Lee.
That's what,
that's what that's like.
That's,
that's what kind of a battle that is.
Just holds them.
It doesn't matter what he does.
You're not going anywhere.
Wow.
And this a praying mantis is a mother fucker,
man.
Just hold on home and starts eating the,
yeah,
that's a weird world.
It's just tiny,
tiny,
tiny seed.
We don't freak,
but if it was big,
it would be way more ruthless than what we're seeing.
Like even amongst mammals,
like Predator mammals,
when we see like a lion take out a gazelle,
like I guess that's not as creepy to me because they're mammals.
Yeah.
If I saw a giant praying mantis take out a gazelle,
I'd be way more freaked out.
The way they look at it looks more alien.
Yeah,
they're weird.
Bugged out eyes and they're crazy arms and their antenna that gets some kind of
weird internet.
All of it,
man.
If a praying mantis didn't exist and you got to see this,
you'd be like,
oh,
what if this was a character in a movie?
Like what planet is this on?
Yeah.
That easily could be.
If it was large,
it could be an alien in a movie like the movie alien.
If that thing was chasing you,
that'd be just as scary.
Oh yeah.
Big giant ass fucking crab arms.
It's going to clamp a hold their pride designed after the praying mantis.
I've some animal like that.
Yeah,
I bet there's probably definitely some influence those cause if you think about
like bugs,
bugs are just like what those aliens were like the alien.
They were like this emotionless,
ruthless thing.
They just like started of popped out of the darkness and clamped a hold of you
and fucking shot a tongue and your brains sucked your brain.
How is that any different than when we just saw that thing?
Yeah.
You don't see any humanity because the eyes don't look the same that Matt like
you can't like identify with it.
You're like this is a foreign species and this giant is coming at me to rip my
heart out of my chest.
Yeah.
That's kind of exactly what it is.
Like the difference between when we see like a cat eat a gazelle,
you know when you see a cat,
wow.
What is this madness versus hummingbird?
No.
Why?
Okay.
What happens?
There's just three of them.
Well praying mantises kill hummingbirds dude.
Really?
Yeah.
So hummingbirds are scared of him.
There's a,
there's a video of a hummingbird with a praying man is in his mouth.
It's really fucked.
Or a praying mantis with a hummingbird in his mouth.
Looks site.
They jacked him there are super small.
So they attacked him.
Where did they attack him or hearings and those things are fucking aliens to
awesome hummingbirds.
Yeah,
they're beautiful.
Where's he jack them?
You know,
the smallest hummingbird is the size of a dime.
Really?
Yeah.
I saw one.
I went to,
I did a dissection.
Ah Shit.
Oh Dude.
The gas wins.
Holy Cow.
Look at this.
It's waiting and the hummingbird gets close and when the hummingbird goes
through the food,
it attacks a hummingbird.
Watch this.
This is crazy,
dad.
I'll get this
swap.
Ah,
look at his bank.
Took him down.
It was a suicide bomber.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
That's what,
that's how scary.
Those things are.
Things bigger than him.
Okay.
Fuck funny.
Praying.
Mantises they did it more threatening name.
Yeah.
Right.
Cause it stands weird.
It's also killed hummingbirds.
Well it's the prey is p.
R.
E.
Y.
It's not like praying mantis.
I think it is a why.
Right?
Is it because they did the way that they yeah.
Yeah.
Oh,
it is the way they stand.
Yeah.
I always thought it was praying.
Yeah,
because of what I mean.
Yeah.
It would suck if they spelled it pray and they were just,
no,
no.
The only tag a fucking snake.
Oh my God.
No,
no way.
Snake.
Yeah.
If we get kicked off of Youtube,
fuck fucking planet.
I'm tired of this shit.
[inaudible] has also led a,
the the dude's to Bethlehem.
I remember.
If I remember you making shit up now.
I think that's a real,
a praying mantis.
Jackson's snake,
a corn snake about 10 inches in length.
That's about what size my Dixon.
We'll just keep on pushing it back and forth.
Confused a little.
Are you trying to trick the algorithm?
I ain't going to work.
Fucking negative bitch.
Yeah.
Put it negative.
What did we just see?
Whoa.
You turn that back to regular.
I need to see what his approach was.
Well,
he's upside down by demanding it.
That's insane.
He's upside down and he reached down and snatched a snake.
They're so evil fro critical.
This snake isn't capable of free itself from the grip of this 16 inch from that
office.
That's amazing.
Danger of being eaten alive by being insect.
It's just eating it upside down.
Look at that poor snake too.
He's like,
what the fuck?
Nobody eats me.
I'm a snake,
man.
Yeah,
you're supposed to be using your leaf.
I thought
it's amazing how much stronger insects are green.
Mathis loses its oh you pussy corn.
Snake escapes.
No Jiu Jitsu.
Bad position.
We didn't hear as a praying mantis.
Go like go tell your friends.
Yeah,
I'm letting you live.
you have no friends.
I'm in town,
man is versus tarantula.
I don't want us praying mantises and monitor showing off at this point.
I was like praying man.
His first versus teenage boy.
They're like,
well no putting minutes versus
very praying mantis versus kitten.
I bet that's out there.
Oh that would be great.
I bet it's out there.
Is it out there?
Yeah.
Shit versus,
yeah,
I gotta wash that.
How's that possible?
That's nuts.
So the idea is that it's hands are out.
Like it's praying.
Like it's like,
oh,
look at this praying mantis versus Tarantula Jack to tranche law.
It's saying,
please come fuck with me.
Holding onto the transla.
I think once it gets those clamps on you,
all those bugs are fucked.
They can't do shit about it.
Once you get those clamps.
That's weird,
man.
Wow.
Is that cat one bad night?
Catlin.
Really?
This is crazy how strong the thing is.
Look,
it just holds on.
it just hooked that fucking praying mantises head or that a tarantula.
His head and the channel just like,
let me go bitch.
He's like,
nope,
there's so much stronger.
Look,
it's just eating it.
Biting its legs and Shit.
They're praying for mercy.
Oh,
but turn around so it turns it around.
Whoa.
Oh,
you got jack son over.
He's jacked.
Look,
he's upside down.
Writhing in pain.
Oh,
is that the end?
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Who shut the video of their guy's an asshole.
That board at that point.
That's like the hut.
Is this a part?
One of a 10 part trailer?
Yeah.
Two hours later.
Grampian versus turning Japanese.
You know what?
What Japanese bug fight stuff.
Can you look up what the praying Mantis is afraid of?
Who Prep?
Pull up the praying.
Praying mantis versus kitten.
This is awesome.
No,
no,
no.
Don't worry.
Kittens.
Fine.
I got it.
It's wild to see man.
It's wild to see you.
See how gangster a praying man.
It's really is.
That's how you see how gangster they are.
Put that.
No,
no,
no.
This,
this one.
This one here.
Praying mantis boxing.
Praying mantis versus kitten.
Sorry.
This one.
Boxing.
Yeah.
You got to see this.
This is so ridiculous.
Like they're going to war.
The kitten and the pragmatics are fucking throwing down to the death.
Yeah.
This is a look at this.
This is fucking praying mantis.
He's not scared of Shit.
That kitten fucks him up.
Bitch.
What bitch?
Swat.
But look at him and he's still up.
Still swinging at the kittens.
The kitten doesn't know when to bite him.
He's scared to bite him.
Look at them.
Fuck him up.
No pop,
pop,
pop.
Look how tough a praying man this is.
It takes a blow to the head by something way bigger than it.
Who is that guy speaking?
Mood.
Okay.
Don't do that Brian.
You ruined the performance.
This cat's doing a great job praying masters all fucked up.
Just standing eight count.
Oh it goes right back to boom body slam.
We can jump.
That wasn't a jump.
That cat bit him in the head.
Okay,
look at him.
He's still fighting back though.
It's crazy.
And the cat is obviously scared of him a little bit because he's so fast.
Oh,
another bike.
You're fucked up son.
I didn't know they had like wings like that.
Yeah,
look at that thing.
What a creepy ass alien bug.
1000000th.
The size of that cat.
It's still fighting back.
Oh Shit.
How many praying men and body wastes and body body weight.
How many praying man,
this is,
does it take to equal that cat?
My Cat's about 10 pounds.
Yeah.
Praying Mantis is about two ounces.
So 16 ounces is a pound.
Yeah,
that's a lot bigger
cause the mathematics
it did.
He's just jacked it.
It's down now.
He must've been it in the head.
Now he's like,
what?
Bitch?
It's on his back again,
bitch,
bitch.
That's why you and your head bitch pop.
The praying Mantis is still trying to fight back
the camera to widen out and there's just like a circle of like Filipino dudes
like betting money on the whole thing.
Yeah,
probably right.
That's a good thing to bet on.
Like how long a praying mantis last with a cat?
Yeah.
I had no idea until this podcast.
How gangster praying mantises where
I know I want to know like taking my know who who,
who preys on the praying mantis like who's their predator?
Like their direct predator.
That's a good question.
Predator to the praying mantis.
I,
here's a mouse versus a fucking praying mantis.
That's gotta be some kind of bird that's like tougher than hummingbird.
Hmm.
Yeah.
What are the enemies of a praying mantis?
Okay,
let's find out.
Can I check this out real quick?
Cause I don't want to say too much of this video because it's,
they look,
oh,
we jacked a mouse.
That's incredible.
Fucking crazy.
God.
Show that again dude.
Shut that again.
I don't care if they pull us off.
You
see this,
look at this,
this mouse.
It doesn't move.
Wow.
Oh,
the mouse soon draws its last breath.
It's an odd site
to watch an insect devouring a memo.
Yes.
Yeah,
it is.
That's the most gangster insect in the insect world,
period.
It's gotta be,
it's gotta be,
I mean,
it doesn't have any venom.
It's doing all this shit with no venom.
Yeah.
It's got like those big praying man,
his hands or whatever.
It's essentially just doing Jujitsu and eating it.
Yeah.
He just does Jujitsu and then just starts eating.
He holds them in side control and just eat the shit out of him.
Wow.
Hey,
it's weird because the one that was on my patio,
it was right next to where I was sitting the whole day and wing it.
You know,
it just stared at me.
His head would like look like when like my girlfriend came outside,
it would look over at my girlfriend and then looked back at me,
but like I would walk next to it.
It never flew away.
Never move.
Yeah.
The only thing I've,
uh,
the dog started like it's trying to sniff it and it,
and it kind of looked down.
I like get away from me.
It was probably one or two.
It's probably looking at you in the
fucking stupid later.
It's like boxing an oak tree or something like that.
Like working out.
It was like,
I think he's vulnerable.
He just,
I feel like I could get them,
but just not quite big enough.
Yeah.
Come on man.
They're getting into modeling at that.
They're modeling,
they're breaking into entertainment.
That's dance.
Progressive Dance.
That's it.
Put that picture up again,
man.
The next thing that we'll look at the body on that thing.
It's so weird.
What a strange animal and how horrific would that be if that thing was like
horse sized and just chasing after you.
That's it going like now what bitch?
Like the something on the ground.
Fucking mouse.
Do you imagine the physical strength to one of those things?
It was like the size of a horse.
Oh yeah,
dude.
It would,
they'd be tearing apart cars when I was like,
I'm going to hide my car.
No,
they just rent the car open.
Easy.
That's the one that was yours.
Look at a man.
Evil.
Fucking crazy.
We're just so lucky that they're little.
They're like the bugs from starship troopers,
right?
Yeah,
kind of.
That's like the best analogy or the best look like him.
They had it in model like directly after.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Right.
The starship trooper bugs are fucking awesome.
That was a silly movie.
But what are you doing Brando before and after he role in Godfather.
Before makeup and after makeup.
Oh really?
Wow.
That's amazing.
Oh,
so they made him look older.
I didn't know they did that.
He almost looked like it.
Like a George Clooney.
Brad Pitt Combo right here.
Oh,
he was a handsome man when he was young.
What?
What does that have anything to do with what we were talking about?
God Damn.
Conversation killing.
They were talking about a green bug that destroyed that starship troopers movie
was a what that would,
that's very realistic in terms of like if there was an invasion by bugs,
we would be getting killed.
Oh yeah.
If there was bugs like that.
Do we even have like what kind of guns would it take to shoot down at giant
praying mantis?
You'd have to have some fucking serious fire power,
like a regular rifle.
It's not going to do it.
I'll give you shot a shotgun and a praying mantis.
The shit would probably work a sheriff,
but probably I wonder if they were like,
they're armors and like paneling.
I don't know if it's like a,
like an Armadillo is just like straight through,
but they seem like they have like,
like Batman has like panels and move around.
It seems like that's what they are like why bet they grow shit back to,
I bet they're like lobsters and a lot of other bugs when they snap off a wing or
something like that.
They just grow it back.
You took this photo?
Oh yeah.
That was the praying mantises in my yard.
Here's is like Brown.
That one was like on vacation.
Well I think he was.
I think he was being camouflage or they can change color?
I'd think so.
Really?
I didn't know that.
I think so.
Okay.
Can mantas camouflage.
Let's see.
That'd be cool.
Yup,
they can.
Wow.
No idea.
Yup.
Defense and camouflage.
Yeah,
so that's what that thing was doing.
That's what the thing was doing in my yard.
If you look at it,
it's on that stone ball,
which is the top of a fountain and it's it blended in to the exact same color.
Wow.
That is so cool.
Yup.
Pretty Weird.
Praying mantis can camouflage perfectly into environment of sticks,
barks,
leaves and flowers.
The mantas is almost four inches long,
blah,
blah.
Mom,
the most evil looking one would be a red one if it camouflage on the like,
you know,
something red.
It can be crazy eyes.
They can be green,
Brown,
or a combination of colors to match their environment.
It will mold every few weeks and then can take on the colors of its natural
surroundings.
Wow.
A praying mantis might even mimic the charred remains of sticks.
Weeds or grass after a fire.
Ooh.
Oh,
got it.
Started
swaying repetitively from side to side as a common California
behavior.
The praying mantis might be used to mimic the swing movement of vegetation in
the wind.
Wow.
Where was that?
This is a video you posted about.
Oh yeah.
That was his gangster praying mantis at the comments.
Wait a minute.
What's this?
Oh,
this is that.
The parasite Geicos a Zombie praying man.
It's revealing a huge parasite living inside of it was,
oh no,
no,
no.
This is not what I'm talking about.
I thought this was something else.
Oh,
that's right.
He killed it and there's something inside of it
that parasite just coming out of it.
Whoa.
Like a snake inside of it.
Yeah.
That's essentially like that movie.
The strain back then.
I'm so we could see that whole thing pop out.
Oh Jesus Christ.
That's so weird.
Welcome to the world of bugs.
This is,
this episode is Nicu.
Sif is hilarious.
And the world of bugs look at that thing also by my name album.
Yeah.
Also buys come album and don't think about this black dick coming out.
Oh my God.
Dead praying,
man.
Wow.
So when the body died,
the parasite left it weaseled out.
Wow.
That is so fucked.
Look how big that thing is,
man.
It's like,
it just keeps going.
What doesn't know what to do either.
Yeah.
It's so big.
Oh my God.
It's the entire body of the thing.
That's incredible.
And it doesn't,
the Mantis didn't look like it was like fat or anything.
And that spray that's on the ground,
that's the poison.
Right?
So it's,
it's a rolling around in the poison.
It's still going.
That is so that parasite controlled the,
the like,
like a Zombie.
He controlled the,
uh,
the Mantas.
Well,
there's an aquatic worm.
I don't know if that's the same one that it gets inside of a grasshopper and
when it's about to be born,
when it reaches the right size,
it actually takes over the mind to the grasshopper and gets the grasshopper to
commit suicide.
So it hot wires.
Look at that thing,
man.
It looks like a snake.
Totally looks like a snake.
I would
not swallow that.
Yeah,
you would for like a lot of money though,
right?
How much,
how much you do,
you have to get to how big it would grow inside of you.
I look at human size of it.
When the guy grabbed it and touched it,
that is some alien invasion shin
type shit there.
That's what that is.
And what if there's a parasite living in that Paris?
That dude do
crazy.
Right?
I'm wonder.
That's good.
Like there's parasites.
I did that live in humans.
Oh yeah.
It just grown your intestines.
Yeah.
That's bizarre.
From live Sushi.
Yeah.
People get it from fresh water Sushi.
They say that you shouldn't really be chewing down too much salmon.
Salmon Sushi.
That's where you catch it.
Like freshwater stuff that lives in fresh water.
Yeah.
Fuck man.
Check this out.
This is creepy.
Uh,
what the fuck?
Look at their eyes.
It looks like like digital.
That's the last thing that mouse saw.
Jesus Christ.
What an evil bug.
A praying mantises.
Hi Guys.
It's kind of thing was clamping down on your face.
The size of a giraffe.
This guys,
it's funny.
It looks like a lot of models.
How dare you,
like when it was Molly really does a lot of models look like aliens?
Is that an eyeball third eye?
Yeah.
Is that what it is or is it just like a good,
it's even spiritual.
It's totally spiritual.
I'm 40 to 10 it's like gold plated in tennis.
They're dope as fuck.
Yo look at that.
That is pretty cool.
It's like,
it's like braided.
It's Persian.
Don't tell Mazda body that joke
bro.
That's so racist.
Yeah.
What does it have to be Persian?
Going to be Mexican because go to studio city.
That's why I go walk around there.
They didn't even look real.
Yeah.
When you see them on a large scale,
you get a sense of what it really is.
When you see those fuckers.
It's not trying to kill a frog.
No,
it's just hanging out on top of it for hog.
Wow.
They're like buddies.
It's like I need a ride.
Wow.
Those things are amazing.
A lot of pictures of frogs and them being friends.
That is a gangster bug but I kind of liked it to translate jacked it cause that
was a battle to the death and torrential one tranche will reverse position and
sunk those teeth in it.
I wonder if in nature though who would have won cause it's camouflaged.
Hmm.
You know what I mean?
Cause that was in the kitchen.
Yeah.
Looks like they said that fight up right before they turn on the camera.
They broke one of the man as his legs.
I'm like,
all right,
go.
Yeah.
I wonder if the praying mantis would go after something as big as a trench a lot
in the wild.
Yeah.
It seems like they're just so evil to go after anything that's in front of them.
The fucking things are attacking birds.
I know in mice and mice and they win and a fucking cat.
That's just crazy.
Yeah.
They don't give a fuck.
They go off to cats like every animal has an another animal they run from.
Would they go,
oh shit.
All right,
I'm out of here.
Yeah.
We own this area,
that praying,
man,
his didn't even try to fly away.
It has wings,
right?
They have wings and he's like,
Nah,
I'll just fucking take my chance.
He took it out.
Can
get some
fucking stupid nose
praying mantises sidewalk.
It's like,
seriously.
That's like you finding a house.
It's like you fighting like a giant elephant,
like a semi truck.
You're smaller than you,
you.
You're bigger in comparison.
Then you would be,
if you were fighting an elephant,
then that thing is to that cat.
What does this wait till you see you in the Mantas?
Oh yeah.
He's like tucked away in there like a flower.
What an evil.
He's pretending to be a flower.
Close quarters.
Some of the safe.
What a creepy ass fucking bug he looks exactly like the color of the flower.
Totally blended in and to hide is something beautiful to look at that that's
what they say about the dads and credible and look at this fly like,
oh,
you know,
just hanging out.
Nothing.
Bitch.
Look how quick it did that.
You can't even see it.
Oh,
and just eat your face.
Eat Him alive.
Wow,
dude.
Back that shit up so we could wash that one more time.
What a bizarre animal.
Let's say for sure where the plant ends and begins.
Second starts.
You really can't tell this elaborate,
brilliant.
The menace to hunt at its leisure account.
Brilliant.
It is.
It looks so much,
I mean,
even the highlights,
the pink highlights like a flower.
Oh,
fast.
Fast.
You can't see shit.
Oh my God.
Pretty.
It's beautiful.
That's like the most beautiful image.
Yeah.
The most beautiful video of something.
Killing something ever.
I know the colors,
like the white with the blue.
Oh my God.
Look at that one.
That's incredible.
That is incredible.
Wow.
It's like we're looking at this image from the and board.
Yeah,
it's gorgeous.
It takes shape as like one of the most beautiful images.
Yeah.
Like who doesn't like a flower?
And they did it perfect.
Like with,
with perfect highlights.
Like I would have never thought about you if you showed me a photo of that and I
didn't watch the video of never thought there's a praying mantis in there.
I would've bet you a lot of money.
Oh yeah.
This is it.
Pray Man.
Minutes in that none.
Zero.
That's a flower.
You fucking idiot.
You need to know what a mess looks like.
Come on on a bet.
Where would it fit in that flower?
Don't be retarded.
You really think you can look that?
No,
it looked exactly like it.
You know what that means?
If they were the size of humans,
they'd be like taking like the shape of like cheeseburgers and like all kinds of
stuff.
Or would it look like the guys from Duck Dynasty?
They'd be wearing Camo.
Right?
Look at that rock in here.
That love that.
It's so weird.
That's so weird that that's a real thing.
I can't,
people do that.
We were lucky people can't do that.
They would be eating people.
The way they manage is eating flies,
you know,
just can't camouflage.
Yeah.
And that would not be good.
People would be hiding.
That's true in your bushes.
This like six people in here that were like,
people will be blown over like the character on x.
Men w mystique.
Yeah.
Mystique.
How come they have a new mistake?
And they didn't even bring that up by the way they,
how'd they go from her bra?
Rebecca Romaine Stamos age.
She got too old.
Oh,
cause it's like,
yeah.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter.
It's a different person.
Don't they have CGI?
They can turn one guy.
You know,
they could turn people into the Hawk and you tell me you can't CGI that check to
look exactly like Rebecca Romaine.
Stamos right.
Come on in son.
That evil fucking thing.
What's it eating their ice cream.
I want work.
That is,
it looks like some sort of a bowling pin off a grenade.
Seen a Turkey leg.
He's got the rent a farm.
That's fair.
I think the bug world is the creepiest world and all of nature.
Yeah.
Second only to the fish world.
Right.
But visual,
it's pretty creepy.
Bugs will look so creepy and they're able to like,
they have multiple hands tentacles,
all these things.
Yeah.
And fish cause you know,
you're like,
well it's out.
If it's out of the water,
it's over.
Put a bug can just get in your bed,
sneaking in your house.
What's the world's largest bug?
Here's a good question.
What would you have if you had to guess,
would you say the world's largest bug is the iPhone.
Okay.
Why are you fucking baby world's largest bug?
Well,
probably like some kind of cockroaches beetle beetle or some kind of something.
That half life thing.
Oh my God.
It's a hit or miss.
It's,
it's this.
Oh my God.
You look like a pill bug.
It's so big.
It's,
this is a gross animal.
Woke up.
The world's biggest insect is so huge and eats carrots.
What?
It's so huge.
It eats carrots.
Look at this thing.
Whoa.
That's like,
exactly.
That's a great,
great sound.
That's real.
Wow.
It's a giant
wait.
A w.
E.
T.
A.
M m came across the cricket like creature,
which has a wingspan of seven inches.
After two days of searching on a tiny island lake barrier island in New Zealand,
it only lives there.
It was a wiped off the mainland by rats accidentally introduced by Europeans.
Pull that picture up again,
man.
Here's another one.
Is that a big grasshopper rice that things gross grass.
It's like a crab or lobster or something which are related by the way.
Yeah.
I was thinking it was going to be something like this,
which was like a pill bug.
I thought that's pretty big too.
Yeah.
That's a Madagascar hissing cockroaches,
isn't it?
Um,
I think that's what that is.
They get pretty big.
Didn't meet one of them.
I ate one of those.
Hold up bad.
Hey,
this is what I thought it was like one of these,
Oh yeah,
those creepy things like cephalopods or something like that.
Those are called like land otters.
Yeah.
Those things have been around for a long
arenas.
They hate,
it's stoner varieties.
The technical name for those things and say,
and that image
I lost of Pod,
loss of Pod,
lots of pod.
I remember that I pod pod I suppose.
Yeah,
that's it.
Jesus Christ.
It's a lobster.
It's like a land lobster that's bigger obviously.
Yeah.
So that's must be the biggest,
but that that has like more than isn't eight legs are more considered like an
insect is six.
Yeah.
I Dunno.
Is that how it works in sac?
Sac being six.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Right?
Like Arachnid is spider
right away?
This is Nikki stuff's new CD.
Oh,
what is it?
Oh yeah.
I forgot about my own album.
It's got a little dot stop.
Dot Downing this oh
Morgan.
It really stopped.
Not only at ladies and gentlemen,
I tunes and all things,
comedy.com please purchase it.
It's my first album and I'm very proud of it.
[inaudible] old school comedy store veteran.
Dude,
you go back.
I know you from,
when did I meet?
You probably met you in
parking lot of the comedy store in 2002,
three and you were a,
you wish to work there.
Oh yeah.
He did the whole stint like Ari,
like a lot of guys.
So yeah,
that's how I met Ari Dunkin.
I worked the phones.
He was the talent coordinator.
Dunkin did the full stint.
I know that's a good stint for comics.
That's the one place where comic can get a job.
Like doing comedy,
being surrounded by degenerates on a constant basis and eventually become a
professional comedian to have his own comedy CD.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I love those stories,
man.
I love watching guys come up in,
in La.
Um,
that was one of the few places where you'd see guys come up.
Joey Diaz is starting to do the comedy store again.
I love that.
That's strange dilemma that,
uh,
since Tommy has
decided to part ways with the comedy serve on to the next stage of a existence.
Suicide did a great ice house chronicles Friday,
by word,
I mean Tammy [inaudible],
Hannibal Buress.
I mean everybody came in because everyone wanted to talk about it.
Yeah.
Everybody wanted to talk about how ridiculous Tommy was.
Yeah,
it's great episode.
Hey man,
he defend them.
You know,
everyone kind of had somewhat defended him as being,
you know,
like this mysterious person and it's probably going to be the end of that part
of the grocery store where it's like,
Ooh,
it's haunted and Oh,
Mitzi.
But,
uh,
I think,
you know,
I,
I showed a couple of the videos that I've made and I think that kind of silence
everyone,
like,
yeah,
he was crazy.
Well,
don't you
deal though to take that job and to try to keep up the legacy of that famed
institution of insanity.
You gotta be a little crazy.
Nobody else wants that job.
Nobody else would have done that job.
They would have turned it into some sort of a corporate whatever,
you know,
fill in the blank.
Sugar Shack.
Chuckle hut.
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean it,
it could have easily been something that it isn't what it is is a very,
very bizarre place as far as comedy clubs go.
One of the most bizarre places of all time and one of the most historical comedy
clubs ever in the world.
Oh yeah,
that's fine.
The Art of standup comedy,
how many historical comedy clubs rival the comedy store?
Very few because it's in the same location.
You know,
you have like a few other ones.
Like the Ice House,
it's older,
you have um,
comedy magic club,
which is older,
the laugh factory,
which has a lot of historical significance.
But laugh factory is not the same.
The laugh factory is not just,
it's a good club.
It's a great club to work at.
But as far as like,
like a place where when you're there you're like,
Holy Shit,
I'm not that goddamn comedy show.
You know,
that was the Mecca because the store like pre produced comics with the ice house
and the other ones just have had them come through.
Exactly.
Yeah.
The stores,
the one of the only places that produced comics all because of Mitzi.
Yeah.
You know that lady,
she helped a lot of Comedians,
me included.
Yeah.
She helped a lot of comedians.
I think if they just keep the open mics as strong as it is there.
I mean like Sundays and Mondays there,
uh,
you know,
they have a really good open Mike Program Killed Tony.
On top of that is,
you know,
really good for them.
I think that you'll still be able to make new comics there and it was still be a
good place for hiring Starbucks employees,
letting them kind of graduate through the system.
Yeah.
And now that,
you know,
you remove some of the crazy aspect as far as like the real negative crazy.
There was just too much ego and madness and just too much intolerable madness is
here.
The best way to describe it.
Like you're not dealing with rational people.
You're dealing with someone who's intolerably crazy and it's not that the whole
intolerable crew is removed.
There's still some in co intolerable behind the scenes folks,
but it's way better now.
It's at least gotten 50% better.
And that other group you never see ever,
ever,
ever there.
So it's,
it doesn't matter.
Yeah.
And you could also go on line to see what we're in when they're out of town and
it's got to that stage that's makes you seem like a stalker.
You know,
I love the Improv man.
I did one thing to change my act quite a bit is when I left the store and I
started doing the Improv,
I found audiences that aren't heckling,
they're not like constantly heckling.
They have actually have crowd control.
And then I,
and then I also noticed that they have two shows a night.
They'll do an eight o'clock show on 10 o'clock show,
which is way better for like the audience's attention span.
And it made me realize like the con,
the comedy store's like lifting weights with like a weight vest on,
running up a hill.
You know when you get to that place,
the great thing about that is you go anywhere else and you're fucking golden.
Yeah.
The regular audiences will be so much easier than the audiences that you deal
with on a weekly basis.
The store,
Oh yeah.
Growing up like after 12 comics,
five six of them are just like crushing crowds drunk.
They'd been there for three hours
and if anything topical happens by the time you get up on stage,
it's been discussed 50 fucking times.
There was a onetime,
when Ari was working there and the Chinese,
a fighter pilot crashed with an American fighter jet and the guy's name was Wong
way.
That was his name.
W.
O.
N.
G.
Weei.
Everybody do a joke on it.
Nobody saw anybody else's sat.
But everybody came in and did a walk.
One way is this real life long way,
do you know the guy's name was Wong Way and at a certain point in time the
audience is like,
are we being trolled?
Is this like an inside joke.
They not know that everybody before them has done a long way joke.
Right.
Even Crowdwork sometimes if you go up like where are you from and someone else
will answer like ice from Lancaster.
Yeah.
Fuck did you know cause he's been asked 10 times.
I love the fact that this happened because it seems like a lot of comics are
coming back to this place that didn't really want it when it come to it.
By the way,
Tosh,
when did apologize for shaking your hand?
Weird last time you saw him Daniel.
Yeah,
but it was cool.
It like seeing tosh and seeing,
yeah,
he said,
he said tell Rogan,
I'm sorry but how I shook your hand.
He's an interesting guy.
He's a great guy.
He seemed very,
he loved that dude.
He was,
he didn't shake my hand weird at all what he's talking about.
He told me to say that to comics are super sensitive
man.
Comics of super sensitive.
There's weird shit that'll stick in a comics head and then they'll bring it up.
Like,
you know,
there was this time where I said this thing and I probably shouldn't have said
any like what are you talking about?
Like I don't even know what the fuck you said.
Yeah.
I called,
I made a joke about something and I really didn't mean it.
I'm like,
I don't remember it at all.
So it's like you're,
you're carrying onto that like holding onto like something they said that you
might misconstrue as a slight or is a joke,
they might not take it.
Well some comics are like super sensitive.
Oh yeah.
Cause you saw,
you want to be like,
you know,
liked and respected and you're just like always worried about saying the wrong
thing because no one knows who you are yet and you're just like,
I want to make friends make a good first impression.
But again,
like Daniel Tosh,
he shouldn't.
Oh yeah.
That's a weird multimillionaire.
I know.
Awesome.
Beautiful Man.
He's a good dude.
He's fun to be around too.
He's hilarious too.
He's like candor.
When you talked to him about like other comedians and shit?
Like he was ragging on this one comedian that he's had difficulties with and it
was God damned hilarious.
Brian Callen and I were crying laughing.
It was really funny.
That's funny.
It's very interesting.
But the um,
you know,
the Improv has guys like that.
They're there all the time.
I wonder if guys like they'll start showing up at the store now too.
Yeah.
David spade was there yesterday or did he stand up again?
I guess that was,
yeah.
How was it?
It was all right.
He was working on a couple of new bits.
Yeah.
Like notes up there with them.
So,
but the kid,
some funny stuff about like going skiing for the first time.
He had like a story on that and all the names of all the slopes were like these
like horrifying like evil names.
You're like Hitler's abortion was the one of them.
Just stuff like that.
It was really funny.
But you could tell he was like developing it and it's like,
it's interesting to see him when I would lie to stand up live.
Well,
he probably like took some time off doing a lot of TV and shit.
And then while those guys,
they lose their chops,
man,
they don't,
they have like a hard struggle to try to get back getting back,
nor McDonald's been there if he had arms becoming their love him.
I love him wrong.
Yeah.
If he comes up,
kidnap him and drag him to this podcast,
I'd love to do it.
But I wouldn't
say he's like,
he's a,
he's a character man.
He's a character.
We were on a plane with him once and uh,
all the way on the plane,
he's talking about how he quit smoking,
quit smoking gun.
I know he's like talking lands immediately goes and buys cigarettes.
Brian let me buy him a cigarette.
He immediately ran and got a pack of cigarettes and he was outside.
I sound,
I guess I'm smoking again.
It's so funny.
But the funniest guys are like that man.
They're just nutty,
nutty.
You know,
that's,
um,
that comes with the territory,
right?
So have you been asked a million times if you'll go back to the comedy store now
that
at least 10.
All right.
Not a million,
but at least 10 when do Friday killed our Monday killed.
Tony's not was something happening,
but uh,
I'm happy.
I'm happy that uh,
the place we'll get more normal.
Yeah,
that's for sure.
And this would be more relaxed.
There's just too much insanity there with that guy running shit.
Absolutely.
He was,
you know,
I don't hate the guy,
but there's just certain levels of intolerable bullshit where you're just like,
okay,
you're too crazy.
You were on this matter.
Hi.
Well,
you know,
but clip my more town to than anyone here.
Yeah.
Let's tell person in this building.
God.
Power and moneys behind me.
That's your hats.
And the building likes me.
No.
So happy.
Yeah.
Someone was saying like,
it would have been great if the way they fired him was a Blake bringing them
into an office and they go like,
well,
it's not just that,
Tommy,
let's start with that.
And then they fire him.
Then he goes,
no,
it's not that.
It is just that this time you're done.
How much?
Um,
uh,
torney doing,
um,
mother as much as I'd like,
but I'm going to Chicago with Ari the end of August.
Oh Shit.
Oh she does?
Zane.
He's downtown.
That's a good spot.
Yeah.
We're doing one night,
I'm going to hang out in the city for a couple of days.
Beautiful.
I opened for Bobby still,
which is good.
Bobby flay.
Bobby Lee.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
Good.
Davinia he's a good dude.
Yeah,
he really is.
He's one of those guys that like is,
he's good to younger people.
You know,
a lot of guys like get,
get to the top or wherever and then they're just like,
they did quit stand up or they don't have any time for newer guys and stuff,
but he's always been super cool.
Yeah.
He got shit on a little bit when he was coming up,
you know?
So I think because of that,
you know,
he had a bunch of issues with guys that were,
that he was working with that just either didn't pay him or fucked with them or,
so he's,
he's super nice to people that are coming up now.
Yeah,
it's pretty great.
He takes care of comics and like he gives like even like way new comics that are
like,
oh I'd like to like open free on a local thing and he'll likely,
you know,
let them have a few minutes just cause he knows,
he remembers what that was like.
Like doing an an not an open mic of any kind and they'll,
this is going to be 80 people.
There are like 200 they're like,
you know,
and he's like,
cause it'll be like a something local.
And he's like,
yeah,
if I can come down to five minutes.
Yeah.
Camaraderie between comics is one of the coolest things.
It's one of the coolest things because it's a,
it's one of the things about the store as well as a store because everybody,
we're all hung out there like really foster that sort of camaraderie.
There was so much fun just in that back parking lot area.
Just the hilarious conversations that we've had back there that was just a,
it was a mad mad club or we run out of time,
three minutes left,
three minutes and we turn into a pumpkin.
So everybody go by Nicu says use of new CD and it is,
what is it called?
Why stop not owning this stopped not owning this.
And is it available on iTunes?
It is on iTunes and all things.
comedy.com for those of you who hate iTunes,
I also get more money if you buy it and all things comedy.com but if you're an
iTunes guy,
totally go there.
It's on their rate it and review it.
I think that helps.
Right?
Yes,
that'll definitely help.
And this will help too.
So Nick Yusuf,
follow him on Twitter.
It's Y.
That's why o u s s e f and nick is spelled normal and I c k nothing crazy.
Yeah,
no Q and a queue.
Well,
hey man,
thanks for doing this.
This is fun.
We got to do it more often.
Yeah,
I love you,
right.
We learned so much about praying man and almost like picture frat again.
I didn't know anything about this was fun and it was actually,
it was sort of like work in some way.
I think we hijack the system.
Make use of ladies and gentlemen,
Powerful.
Nick.
Yusuf,
please go out and buy shit.
It was a very funny comedian.
Uh,
thanks to our sponsors.
Let me pull them up because I don't have it on my thing anymore.
squarespace.com Squarespace.
Thanks to Squarespace.
Yeah,
for uh,
just nothing but positive feedback.
I haven't heard one person say anything bad about Squarespace,
which is a beautiful thing.
And a,
if you go to squarespace.com,
forward slash Rogan's edit,
no,
squarespace.com enter in the code word Joe.
So for a free trial and 10% off your first purchase,
go to squarespace.com and enter in the code word Joe.
And thanks also to who else do we have today?
Tanked and go to [inaudible] Dot [inaudible] Dot Com and save 25 bucks off of
any of these new fantastic cell phone devices that tank cells as rogan.ting.com
the official cell phone provider for the Joe Rogan experience podcast.
Thanks also to [inaudible] dot com go to o n n I t use the Codeword Rogan and
save 10% off any and all supplements tomorrow.
Shooter Jennings,
son of the great Waylon Jennings.
That's right.
Bitches respect until then,
uh,
much love and big kisses.
See Ya.
[inaudible].